Um, Charlie has decided that he is going
finally step up and and be like a content creator again who does
commentary on things. Okay, it's it's here. He's ready to go.
Uh, Charlie has done a video. I believe this is going to be on
Coffeezilla's video. I don't know if it's going to be on anything
else. Oh, no. He's just he might just be doing it himself. It's
like Coffeezilla's video on the FS short and a couple other things.
Okay. And I believe that his take is the correct one. It is,
hey, this is the most corrupt government we've ever had that's
only using the government to enrich themselves, and it's insane
that nobody's calling it out. All right, that's the that's the
idea. And I think a couple people have gone after him for this.
I know. I saw as watching it today and I saw I got linked a video
of another going after him. Okay.
And I'm down to check this out. I want to check this out. So,
first we're going to watch Charlie video. I might speed it up
a little bit because it's Charlie and sometimes he could be a
little slow with delivering his points. But maybe maybe Charlie
is uh deciding to grow some balls and be a creator again. That'd
be cool, right? If he didn't just give Reddit opinions all the
time. Although this one, I guess, probably would be a Reddit
opinion. But hey, sometimes broke clocks right twice a day. Okay.
>> In control was just something you see in comic books
and cartoons. But now I know it's a very real thing that you
can see happening daily in this country. Now, the big thing I
want to talk about, I'm going to talk about a lot here. There's
gonna be a bunch of blabber in here and drool coming out of my
mouth as I'm spitting because I'm about to be getting pretty
passionate. And the big focus is on the huge crypto collapse
uh from yesterday. And the very suspicious, very lucky trader
who was able to cash out $190 million off of it because they
were shorting Bitcoin and Ethereum a day before and all the way
up until a minute before Trump's Truth Social Post announcing
the massive tariffs on China, which crashed the entire market.
and then 30 minutes later they cash out $190 million. It seems
like they might have known something, but that can't be right.
That would be corruption. And this administration doesn't engage
in that kind of nefarious activity except for all the previous
times that this exact same thing has happened with Trump announcing
things on Truth Social that people close to a suckless tit must
have had insider knowledge on because they're able to cash out
millions upon millions of dollars because of his rinse and repeat
cycle of threatening tariffs, backing off tariffs, postponing
tariffs, just fluctuating the market up and down. Yet people
in his inner circle must be privy to this knowledge cuz they
are making absolute bullseye trades based on that before it becomes
public. So this isn't really >> Yeah. Obviously if only
if only the SEC was able to operate
in any reasonable fashion, right? >> Anything new. It's
just the most egregious instance because you can literally see
it. This account opens and starts shorting Bitcoin and Ethereum
a day before. >> Uh I swear to God if he this up I'm going
to rage. I don't think 99% of people understood what actually
happened. understand what actually happened. Wait, you mean beyond
is there something more complicated here, tourniquet, other than
this uh this guy like
putting shorts in leading up to these tariffs being announced
or the 100 the new trade war going on with China?
Is there is there like something more explicit than that that
happened? Like was he was he leveraging is he using like flash
loans or something?
>> Okay. All right. this announcement and then a minute
before the truth social post goes live like it's it's unbelievable
and if you are a MAGA cultist it actually is unbelievable they
refuse to believe it they refuse to accept the very real reality
that they are getting posed Trump and Trump's family's net worth
has exploded since becoming president how do you defend that
well I'll tell you how because they say Trump is such a benevolent
saint he actually doesn't even keep his salary from being president
Wow that's how much he cares about the American people you delusional
homunculus the presidential salary is actual peanuts literal
used condoms in the grand scheme of how much money him and his
family are making throughout his presidency when he was >> Dude,
Charlie Charlie broke out the the thesaurus for this one. Oh
my god. Delusional homunculus. The you delusional homunculus.
Guys, I'm going to get guys, I'm going to get pretty passionate
for this one, just so you know. You delusional homunculus.
>> That's crazy passion. >> Hillary is actual peanuts.
literal used condoms in the grand scheme of how much money him
and his family are making throughout his presidency. When he
was being sworn in, he was still launching up to 168 new products.
And that doesn't even include things like his cologne that he
launched. You know, the [__] Trump Gucc galore smell,
the Trump watches, the Trump phone and [__] like
that. So, that has only increased the amount of things that he
is hawking to the American people to buy solely to enrich himself
and his family, his meme coin and all of that. His family is
going ballistic in terms of how much money they are making off
of his presidency. They're not even hiding it. They are just
constantly making money off of you. As you suffer and get less
and less money, they get more and more. They are taking the pizza
and not even leaving you bits and pieces, morsels of the crust.
It's It's sad. And yet people love it. They will accept it with
a smile on their face and ple and say, "Please give me some more.
I've got more holes for you to fill. Please." >> Yes. Oh
my god. Listen, I may not like Charlie, but is he's he is hitting
all the notes. I wonder if he'll talk about the DOJ at all here.
>> Come in here. I'm waiting. It It's just absurd. They
don't even stick to a single belief anymore. Like the Epstein
files. I know I have made a lot of content on in the past, so
I'm not going to regurgitate that, but the Epstein files are
a really good example of how they really cared about the Epstein
files, and they were really upset at the failure of Joe Biden
to release them in that administration. So, they were hyping
up Trump about all of his promises to release those Epstein files,
which he has still not done and still actively just like discounts
in the entire ad administration denying the existence of now.
And this same group of people that was so excited for Trump to
follow through on that promise is now like, "Oh, we didn't break
any promises. In fact, it's just not even important. That's why
he's not doing it." Like, it's not a big deal. Like, who cares
about the Epstein files? We have so many bigger things to worry
about, like what the next product we're going to have to buy
from Trump is. Like, they're just now saying it doesn't matter.
We don't care. We actually don't want this information. Actually,
I believe everything they're saying now. Yeah, it definitely
doesn't exist. Yeah. Actually, Maxwell is probably innocent,
too. But again, I I've already talked about that a lot. Let's
talk about some other stuff. The COVID vaccine. The the real
issue, right, isn't people because I think people are willing
to or people are still pretty pissed about the Epstein Files.
The real problem
these
politicians who made the Epstein Files something they campaigned
on and they've totally flipped with no explanation, right? Cuz
they at least with regular people, they have an excuse. They're
regular people. They're not informed. But with the politicians,
you literally are. You that's your only job is to be informed.
How the did you flip on this? Trump just got a COVID booster.
Not a conspiracy, just out in the open, signed, documented, stamped.
It is legitimate. Trump just got a COVID booster. And this administration
has constantly played into the MAGA fear of the jab. That was
one of the big things with MAGA is like how this is, you know,
contaminating us. Oh god. Oh god. Oh god. He No. No.
Is this the only time that he that you could like point a Trump
wrongdoing out and it's like wrong?
Didn't Trump like largely lean into the the COVID vaccines being
good because he did Operation Warp Speed? I thought all through
the campaign he was still going, "Yeah, the vaccine was good."
And I know you guys don't want to hear it, but the vaccine was
good. I thought I thought Trump was the guy. That's probably
why he got a booster cuz he wants to take all of the credit for
Operation Warp Speed. So, I think this is maybe the one case
where the administration didn't do this, >> poisoning us.
They're trying to us with the jab. And now Trump just got the
vaccine booster. And those same people like Gunther Dicklman
are now applauding him for it. Sucking a
>> Oh, I see. Hold on. Hold on. Gunther Eagleman influencers
might have done this. Fart out of his butt for it, giving him
a full rim job. Like, yes, the president's healthy. This is great
news. Meanwhile, only a few months ago, a big talking point from
him and so many others is the COVID vaccine and the evil of it.
But now that Trump got the vaccine booster, well, now they love
it. Well, now it's great. Actually, Trump probably got the vaccine
booster because he's going to immediately give all of us herd
immunity. He is using himself as a selfless sacrifice with the
jab. So that way his aura of being immune to COVID will help
infiltrate all of us via osmosis. So now we're
>> Is this Gunther account a real person? Uh it's definitely
not a real person. It's definitely some
it's like some OP or somebody who's running it for for like money.
Like it's it's being done with an interest and it's it's obviously
not a real person. I'm sorry. It's just obviously not. >> We're
all immune to CO thanks to Trump getting the COVID vaccine booster
or some crazy [__] Maybe that one. I'm just spitballing,
but I'm trying to find ways to mental gymnastics around it. But
the sad reality is they're not even going to bother trying. They're
just going to be like Gunther here and just be like the good
little NPC drone that's like anything Trump does is great. Can't
wait to swallow more Trump meats. Even though it goes completely
against all of the things he was talking about. Like so many
people that were talking about the jab and how evil it is and
all of that are now celebrating that Trump got it. That's just
it's just so obvious. It's so blatant. Like cat turd. I I don't
think I've seen anything from him on Trump getting the jab here.
Just radio silence. Just crickets. It's just ignore things that
make you have to think. That is the cult mentality of manga.
Anything Trump does is perfect. Anything that makes me think
that maybe there's something else there, I shut out. I plug my
ears to. It is [__] horrifying. Trump is now building
a Qatari Air Force base in Idaho. Trump has >> uh Gunther
is more real than most of the bots. He is also a convicted felon.
Basically, Cat turd three. Okay.
>> Wait, is he like is his real name Gunther? I just assume
it was uh I thought I thought I I'm almost positive I got told
he was like uh he's a part of like some group that like does
this that has like a lot of these accounts. I didn't think he
was like just a bot. I thought he was Yeah. Like cat turd where
he was like it it's it's like a pseudonym. It's not that's not
who he is. Gunther Eagleman is not a person.
>> A huge $400 million wombo turbo superstar jet from Qatar.
I It's a crazy gift. That's one hell of a donation there. I don't
want to toss the B- word around too lightly here, the bribe.
Nomenclature, but I mean, definitely smells a little fishy over
here with that, especially in regards to what came soon after.
He then signed a $5.5 billion deal with Qar for a Trump golf
course. Yippee. That's great for the American people. More Trump
wealth that he accumulates here through this deal. And now he
is putting a Qatar Air Force base on our homeland soil. America
first, right? Yeah. It's really America. So, I've heard this
that the Qataris are building an air force base here. >> Is
it like I'm guessing I'm guessing it's going to be like American
equipment where they train an American equipment and learn how
to fly from American pilots so they can go back to Qatar and
like actually be pilots in an air force there that didn't exist
previously.
Is that not Would that not be what it is? Oh, let's look it up.
God damn it. You want me to do work? Fine. Atari Air Base, Idaho.
What is going on here? Things to know about Qatar training facility
planned for Idaho Air Force Air Force Base. Qatari training facility.
Like the literally the first thing I read is exactly what I said
with no knowledge of the situation because I'm like probably
that wouldn't make any sense and the US would never allow it.
Right? When US Defense Secretary Pete Hexit announced Friday
morning that the federal government had reached an agreement
with Qatar to build a facility at an Air Force base in Idaho,
social media posts began popping up online from across the political
spectrum, expressing outrage at the concept of a foreign military
base on American soil. But the facility being built at the Mountain
Home Air Force Base in Idaho isn't a separate base at all. It
is a group of buildings that will be built to handle training
and maintenance for Qatari troops. And the agreement with Qatar
has been in the works for years. Yeah. So, it's obvious that
this would be what it is, right? that you have a you have like
anybody who's anybody knows that Qar doesn't really have a military
presence, right? Like they they barely have a military. So probably
they just got bombed by Israel.
They probably gave this an extra little push and we're like,
"Hey, we need to get this worked out cuz we need to figure out
how to run an air force cuz holy, it really sucks that this country
just came in, violated our airspace, and bombed some people on
our sovereign soil." I'm guessing these things push this along,
right?
But I see a bunch of people talk about this and I'm like, dude,
there's no way they build an air force base. Like, it's
it's obviously true that the US would have to train people on
their equipment
somewhere. And it must be easiest to do that in a place where
you have like air force bases on the ground.
I don't know. Seems like obvious. Uh, in fact, on-site training
agreements with allies are common in the US. The Republic of
Singapore 428th Fighter Squadron Buccaneers have been hosted
at the base since 2008. Oh, at the same base. That's crazy.
Uh, have been hosted at this base. German forces trained at Hullman
Air Force Base in New Mexico for decades or have been. Yeah.
Okay. New facilities to train international F-35 pilots were
completed at Ebing Air Force Base in Arkansas last year. Yeah.
I I don't know. People like read things and they
people read things and they freak out about stuff without like
thinking about it. Like I I don't know that much. I don't even
live in your country.
Like I you should be able to understand that this is like not
a big deal.
How much you think Moyes makes a year for dumbing down his entire
audience? Uh, untold un unheard of amounts of money. Okay. I
think this guy streamed once and he just showed for like a two-hour
stream. He made like $40,000 on YouTube, right? I think he like
he just fired up a stream one day, played some video games, and
he made like 40,000 like 40 grand or something. I think it was
like a two hour stream or some [__] It's like he
just prints money wherever he goes. It's [__] crazy.
>> Yeah. And then I've already seen the cope about how
actually no this is a this is a joint training procedure. This
is something that we do all the time actually. And I saw JD my
chemical romance Vance talking today about >> apparently
apparently I'm the person who doesn't understand. Let's see.
Maybe maybe he's got something else going on >> Like how
it's actually just all fake news and stuff even though they have
literally verbatim point blank said exactly what this deal is
and he is just denying that. So not even the administration is
on in is in agreement on their talking points right now. It's
a mess and still people are so bra. I mean, I just read the Associated
Press
I I'm going to go ahead. I'm going to say something wild. I don't
think the Associated Press has a proTrump bias. All right. I
don't think so. I think that's that's like a crazy thing to >> And
mind control that they'll just accept it. Be like, "This is great.
This is America first, actually, to put this
>> It's unusual to train up the air force of the same group
that Harvard." So you could say that that it's unusual to train
up the air force of the same group that harbored. But that is
a that is a partner that exists in the Middle East who just had
their sovereign soil. I'm guessing this was a part of something
where
uh like this could have been a part of the entire Middle Eastern
deal, right? Very possibly or at least it seems that way to me
that like hey we just got our we just got our [__]
rocked. Could we get some help here? Can you help train our pilots?
Put looked into it and came off with exactly the opposite of
Jtock's opinion. Well, I mean, my opinion was just validated
by the by uh what do you call it?
Uh the Associated Press. I don't know. I don't know how you could
have the opposite opinion when apparently
the Singaporean Fighter Squad has been doing the same thing.
Here's some things to know about the base. Maybe you have to
read more of the article. Hold on. Base is roughly 50 mi southeast
of Boise in Idaho, which is the state's capital and primary population
hub. Sits in the high desert tundra plateau tucked between two
mountain ranges. The spot is ideal for fighter pilot training
because of the because there is a lot of space around the base
to practice maneuvers. It's like basically the Dragon Ball Z
area, isn't it? I can already tell it's like the it's exactly
what they have for Dragon Ball Z. It's like that area. Okay.
Where they always go to some hidden third location with all the
mountains and around no people. That's what this is. Okay. The
base is just outside of the town of Mountain Home, which is home
to about 17,000 people. The new facilities will be built by local
construction crews and local workers will likely be employed
at the base to support the training operations. Stefanic said
the construction and other associated expenses will be funded
by Qar. Security at the base will continue to be handled by the
U by US Air Force personnel. She said and anyone going to the
base will still have to show the proper credentials in order
to enter.
So I guess the argument against this right if we take one tokver's
thing is because these people have funded you know they've definitely
funded although funding like they've funded the civilian operations
of for sure right in at times where the Palestinians couldn't
so I guess the the argument against this would be something like
oh they they don't serve America's interest they're not going
to work with America so they will probably
use information gleaned from this base
to subvert America, right? They've harbored. Yeah, but they've
tried to operate as a like as a safe zone for people, right?
One took over like the leadership of these people like for political
exiles and stuff. So, you could say, well, I don't like and I
don't like that the leadership is housed in Qatar. You could
say that, but I think that they the idea is they would do that
for groups and and that negotiations can hap there happen there
between groups that wouldn't be able to happen elsewhere. Yeah.
No, we all know that leadership was sitting in some Qatari luxury
suites while October 7th was happening and everything, right?
We know that. But I thought that was the point of Qar and I thought
that the US basically gave their blessing to Qatar to do that,
right? The US literally had its protection over Qatar from what
I understand for a long time understanding this, knowing that
Qatar did this. Am I wrong? So how is that like a downside for
the US when they go, "Oh yeah, you should actually be this place.
You should we we'll guarantee your security. You'll be fine.
Right. It seems like nobody in the US was unaware of what Qatar
was doing.
There's a US air there's a massive US air base there, isn't there?
Or am I think of Bahrain? I might be thinking of Bahrain here,
but I thought there's a big US air force base in Qar as well.
Anyway, so the base nicknamed the gunfighter base houses the
366th Fighter Wing of and more than 50 F-15E Strike Eagle aircraft.
It aims to be or it aims to provide mission ready gunfighters
to conduct military operations anytime, anywhere. According to
the website, three fighter squadrons are located there. The 389th
Fighter Squadron Thunderbolts, the 391st Fighter Squadron Tigers,
and the Singaporean 428th Fighter Squadron of Buccaneers. An
air control squadron and Air National Guard Squadron are also
housed at the base. All told, the fighter wing includes about
5100 military and civilian members, as well as 3,500 family members,
according to the website. When was the QAR agreement conceived?
Qatar decided to buy the F-15 QA aircraft from a US government
program called foreign military sales in 2017 and discussions
to train Qatari troops in the use of the jets began shortly thereafter.
Stefanic said work got started on an environmental assessment
to determine the possible impact on the area surrounding the
mountaineer home air force base or on the area surrounding the
mountain home air force base began around 2020 and the assessment
was completed in 2022. Was this about the expansion, the Qatari
expansion, or what was this about just in general for the Air
Force base? I don't know. It seems It seems to me like this is
not even a problem at all. Like, if you were concerned, you would
not sell them the F-15s, right? If you were like that concerned
about training them in fighting with the F-15s, no foreign country
should have a military base on US soil, especially Islam Islamic
countries. So, this is just pro this is just anti-
I'm sorry. this like does this not seem to me it seems to me
like just pure I see Laura Loomer say something I'm like oh that's
Zionist propaganda like immediately what is the issue with selling
somebody the tech and then negotiating to train them in using
that tech I I literally don't I don't
especially when they already do it with other countries I guess
the the probably the major thing you'd be concerned about is
the the bribe that you feel like is a part of getting the training
program set up I don't
I don't know, man. >> Air Force base in Idaho. That's actually
exactly what I wanted. And then Trump always finds a way to surprise
me with some crazy skits posting late at night. So, his most
recent one is uh the Biden FBI placed 274 agents into the crown
on January 6th. >> They bribed him in 2017. No, obviously
the deal and the training deal, the the conception of the training
deal started before 2017 or sorry, before this year. Started
in 2017 as it just said in the article. I'm saying that they
might have bribed him to get the the wheels greased to get the
training program off the ground. Like, hey, we've been like flirting
back and forth on this and you guys are stonewalling us. Here's
like a bunch of money that is going to like I don't know. Yeah.
Grease the wheels >> If this is so, which it is, a lot
of very good people will be owed big apologies. What a scam.
Do something. President DJT.
>> There is so much wrong with that. I I think he forgot
to take his suppositories because holy, Trump was president on
January 6th. Biden did not control the FBI. But you know what?
Let's play ball here and dive into a fever dream, a fantasy.
Let's say Joseph Biden sat down his ice cream, cracked his knuckles,
and assumed direct control of the FBI on January 6th and placed
all of these agents in here just as Trump says. Well, why don't
you do something about it? You are the president? Who are you
asking to do something, God? Batman. Like, who are you trying?
>> I don't think anyone cares about the training part.
The problem is with the New Deal that includes a military base
on top of the training. So, where is the military base? It seems
like they're building like uh like barracks essentially, right?
It is a group of buildings that will be built to handle training
and maintenance for Qatari
but but like it doesn't sound
it doesn't sound like it's a new base. It's just basically they're
building like the bunkers and support structures for the Qataris
to come and be there. And I don't even know. It doesn't sound
like will will Qar even be managing that or is Qatar just paying
the money
to like build this stuff for them like build additional infrastructure
so that we can have these people here and train here? It's not
a military base. I promise you the United States is never giving
like full control over anything like this to another country.
That's insane. I don't know. Anyway, I guess you should probably
figure out what the difference is between this deal and the deal
that got the uh the Buccaneers there, right? We could >> call.
Who are you trying to summon to do something? You are the president.
So, if this is real, why aren't you doing anything? This is a
classic president DJT maneuver here. the entire administration
really where they're like all these crimes from the Democrats.
All of these absolutely abhorrent, vile crimes that the Democrats
have done. No more playing nice. No more Mr. Nice guy. We're
showing our teeth. We're bearing our fangs and we're going to
get something done about it. And then nothing. It's all just
posturing. It's all performative. It is a game. And they are
playing you. They are praying upon your gullibility and your
prop your your inclination to be afraid to constantly keep you
in fear. Because when you are afraid and when you are convinced
that the other side is doing all of these things to get you,
you are so [__] easy to control. You're so malleable.
That's why they're playing that [__] in the airports
now about how like the Democrats are are Satan and all of that.
If you have all of this overwhelming evidence that you claim
to have about all these crimes and all of this [__]
that the Democrats have done, why have you done nothing? You
would be just as guilty in that case. What is the the quote?
The only thing it takes for evil to succeed is for good men to
do nothing. Well, if you know that all of this evil is happening
for the Democrats and you're doing nothing, you're just as guilty.
Like this is so clearly obvious to anyone that's thinking for
more than five seconds. And you don't even need to be thinking
for 5 seconds to see this new truth social stinker here that
he squeaked out as anything other than just a sham. Like this
should just be alarming into the mental decline of Trump. He
was president on January 6th. He controlled the FBI, not Biden.
Biden was probably out riding his bike to a twisty treat. I don't
think he was down there as the puppet master pulling the strings
putting FBI agents in January 6th. This like it's it is so crazy.
And yet people will just swallow it. They will swallow any that
Trump feeds them happily, even when they know it's
>> So, sorry, I'm looking into this on the other side.
So, the only difference between this one and the Singaporean
deal is that Singapore refurbished existing buildings on the
same base and Qatar is paying for new buildings to be built,
right?
So, like I guess you could read the actual Are you saying the
contracts are are published? K1 div like the contract they signed
is published somehow cuz like I am I am shortcutting this and
just looking into things with um with perplexity like we could
read more but to me it looks like they're very very very similar.
Why is Qatar building a an air force training facility at a US
military base? Like I' I've seen nothing that's not just basically
saying this is the same as the Singaporean deal, right? US maintains
full-fledged military bases that house tens of thousands of US
troops in dozens of countries. In Qatar, US service members are
based at aloud air base. The air base was attacked by Iran in
June. It has served as a major staging area for US forces by
supporting operations in Iraq, Afghanistan, and Syria. TAR is
donating a Boeing 747 to the US government. Gift that Democrats
and some Republicans said it was a gift.
Oh, hold on. The US does the same same thing back. What other
countries have training facilities in the United States? German
Air Force has one
command was previously in Hollowman Air. Oh, they're now at an
Air Force base in Texas. They used to be in Mex New
Hundreds of Singaporean Air Force personnel are based at Mountain
Home. They live and work on the base as part of the training
program aimed at qualifying them to operate F-15 fighter jets.
Like Qar, small Singapore's small geographical size forces the
country to send its service members abroad for training. Singaporean
troops also train in Australia, which offers a full a training
ground that is five times the size of Singapore as well as live
fire facilities. It also has an air force squadron based in France.
In 2018, Singapore was authorized to expand its presence at Mountain
Home with Washington approving the construction of additional
support facilities. Pilots from the Netherlands, Britain, and
other NATO allies trained in the United States. I just don't
if somebody could point out K1 normie or Kwan Div, can you tell
me? I read X Normy's name. Kwan Div, can you tell me what the
difference is? I would just love to know what the difference
is between these two agreements. How how are they different?
How do you differentiate the Singaporean agreement from the Qatari
agreement? I I don't see it and I want to see it. I want somebody
to tell me how it's different. Okay, we're back to the Charlie
bad like Ted Cruz saying that he got into Congress 13 years ago
solely to represent the interests of Israel. He is he is an American
politician who openly states that he is here for Israel. That
again, like I said, feels treasonous to me. And I imagine most
people in a different time period would feel the same. But because
of how tribalistic politics has become, if you're a big MAGA
enthusiast Trump supporter, you have to somehow just handwave
that and support it because that's what you're told you need
to do. Even though
even with the same agreement, the countries differ may be the
point. I mean, that's if anybody wants to come and make that
point that um like Qatar can't be trusted as as people who could
be trained with these weapons. I just wonder why you sell them
the weapons in the first place. One tookover, what do you think
of? So the plane doesn't really explain it because apparently
the US was talking to them about doing this for a long time as
well,
right? So I I don't know like it seems like previous US administrations
had totally entertained doing this. They didn't really have a
problem with doing this, right? I just I if somebody can explain
to me why the US would would apparently other administrations
have looked at this as well. >> Anyone should be able to
hear that and be concerned. Why does Israel have such >> Yes.
Yes. uh in 2017 was when they were sold and then I believe there's
been multiple attempts at
like getting these getting these planes um getting getting Qatari
pilots trained in flying these planes. The previous deal was
fine. The Trump deal is different. K1D, please explain. Don't
just say it's different. Explain.
Explain.
Even though anyone should be able to hear that and be concerned,
why does Israel have such a huge strangle hold on the American
political landscape and such a massive say so and how American
companies do their business? And why do they even have like the
ability to start making demands about what needs to be censored
in regards to their atrocities on American platforms? It would
be alarming to everyone if the political sphere wasn't just I
have to support everything from this side no matter what. It
is [__] scary. Now, I do want to make a mention of
something. It's not all horrible awful news. There's actually
a ceasefire going on right now and I can only pray that it sticks.
With Netanyahu, you never really know. But I can only keep my
fingers crossed and pray for the absolute best for the Palestinians
and hope that going forward the people of Gaza will no longer
need to fear being massacred by Netanyahu's IDF. Now, I know
I said at the beginning of the video the focus of this was going
to be on the crypto collapse and the super lucky guy that happened
to make $190 million going against all rational thinking and
against all the odds. Truly a miracle. Okay. So, here's the here's
the again, I'm just using perplexity to put this together because
I I could look into it a little more aggressively if we need
to,
but apparently the difference with
the difference the Biden administration was they they tried to
make it so that buildings would only be refurbished so it couldn't
be spun politically as allowing a foreign country to construct
a military base. Even though explicitly apparently explicitly
with the Qatari deal, the Qataris are just funding. They are
not giving plans. They are not building. They are not managing.
They're not controlling any of the infrastructure that's being
built. They're just funding it. >> But I couldn't help
myself. This is just so preposterous. But now, let's finally
dive into the crypto collapse. Coffeezilla made a video going
over this. It's extremely well put together. So, I'm going to
be showing you some clips of that as we talk about it. >> I
don't even know what this is. I think this is all legal. Kind
of. I don't think it should be. As you'll see, >> thing
is, even if it wasn't legal, it wouldn't matter. there will be
no justice pursued regardless because I think it's pretty clear
that whoever this is, they are part of Trump's inner circle of
cronies and they had this knowledge beforehand what was coming
and it doesn't take a genius to recognize that imposing these
huge tariffs on China was going to have a huge effect on the
market. So, it was a pretty easy opportunity for them to short
with that knowledge in mind and make an unbelievable amount of
money. Again, if it is legal, it shouldn't be like Coffeezilla
says, but even if it isn't legal, it won't matter cuz they're
not going to do anything about it. But the question is, what
did this guy know? Okay, how did somebody make $190 million while
everyone else was losing their shirts yesterday? If you don't
know, there was one of the biggest crashes we've ever seen in
crypto. And someone came in 24 hours before and started placing
shorts against the market. Short is just when you bet that the
underlying asset is going to go down in price and you will make
money on that. Now, this all started October 9th at 1639 GMT
time. They start accumulating this big. Okay, since this since
this K1 diff couldn't tell me, I just asked Quman and Queman's
problem was just Trump getting gifts that he doesn't know how
you get rid of the conflict of interest. That's fine. I think
the conflict of interest the issue is it's it starts to become
like a diff what do you call it? Like a it's like a scale thing
then. Okay, cuz obviously Trump's conflict of interests like
I'd probably just focus on the bigger ones. It's like, yeah,
he did get a gift, but at least this is like not a gift that's
made him pursue a policy that's different than what the US would
pursue under a different administration,
right? So, like, at least there's that where it's like a a policy
most people were willing to go forward with as opposed to like
where you worry about how he's acting like really differently
or doing things that other administrations wouldn't and how his
conflict of interest pile up there. Right? Obviously the conflict
of interest to purely enrich himself when it comes to let's say
uh this exact example the short going on here him refusing to
uh not divert
to dis uh disinvest himself to uninvest to what do you call it
when you put your in a trust divest himself me divest himself
of all of his business interests right like those are conflict
of conflicts of interest that seem much more significant to me
>> Bitcoin short >> so t-minus 24 hours until the
rest of the world knows this information about the impending
tariffs. They come in with $80 million that they start shorting
Bitcoin with. That is not like a gamble or anything. That feels
like they knew for sure something was going to happen. That is
a crazy amount to come out of nowhere with to short Bitcoin.
Now, the amount is unusual, but that's that itself is not the
unusual part. Then we have Ethereum starts to get shorted at
349 GMT. Interesting. 30. Well, Nick, it's like um the plane
to be honest is like a bribe. The plane costs so much to like
maintain apparently that it's just like almost a negative asset.
It's like an incredibly
expensive asset to even hold. Like the Qataris probably just
wanted to get rid of it. Aren't there people that short sell
stuff every literally every day? Yes. But the issue would be
given the direction of the market maximus and what to be what
you could expect, it's likely that this short is like insane
like an insane risk in and of itself. >> $30 million gets
deposited into this account immediately start placing major bets
that the market is going to go down. Why is this significant?
Well, because at 1457, this is only a few hours later, like 12
hours later, Trump posts on Truth Social that they are calculating
a massive increase on Chinese tariffs. >> Zoinks. That's
really lucky. This account comes out of nowhere swinging huge
numbers, slinging big time the balloons here on these shorts.
And then shortly after, well, it looks like something might be
happening to the market here with these potential tariffs that
they're calculating. >> Where I think this goes from suspicious
to downright diabolical is the fact that at this point the market
dips a little bit because you have these threats of tariffs,
but the person does not start closing out their shorts yet. >> No,
that's not weird. This trader's just got diamond hands. What?
He's not going to close out his position based off of just that
one tweet there. No, that wouldn't make any sense. He's just
got strong paws to really grip onto his positions here, which
I think is very interesting. If you place this huge short bet
and then the president tweets something like this, you would
think you would close out your order. But not only do they not
do that, not only do they not close out their short, they continue
to place short bets against Bitcoin. In fact, this person continues
to short Bitcoin all the way up till 204923
GMT.
Why is that significant, ladies and gentlemen? It's because 2049
is the last short he places. Okay? 2050 GMT. A minute later,
one minute later, Trump announces they're considering an 100%
tariff on China, which of course tanks the market. And this person
makes literally $190 billion in 24 hours. Then over the course
of the next half hour, they close out all of their shorts and
they cash out big-time jackpot. Wow, did they get lucky or what?
Huh, man. I cannot believe the kinky dink there. Shorting all
the way up until 1 minute before Trump's tweet. Jeez, some guys
have all the luck. You would actually need to be the biggest,
stupidest trogodite on the planet to think that this was just
like a lucky, you know, miracle trade here from this individual.
This is clearly someone that had information about what was coming.
The speculation is that it's barren. Baron Trump. There's a lot
of people that are providing their loose evidence that it's barren.
Nothing's confirmed on who this is. And I don't think there will
ever be confirmation on who this was. But it doesn't take a Galaxy
brain five-digit IQ genius to see this and recognize that
lane is a distraction.
This is the real quid proquo. Okay, hold on. What is this? Porter
Beller. This does seem like uh I saw another thing from Nyx saying
that Qar had decided they were going to invest a in the US as
well. Uh hold on a
I need to pull this up on stream.
See here. Axios.
All right, let me take a look. Let me take a look. US security
guarantee for Tatar sparks jealousy and confusion. The United
States is promising to treat Qar's security like its own. The
single Trump administration decision. This that single Trump
administration decision sets in motion a geopolitical cluster.
There's confusion and jealousy among Gulf states, questions of
burden sharing among NATO allies amid Trump's push for them to
spend more money and a political meltdown in Israel among other
drama. Uh I could see Israel melting down over this. That sounds
uh like they would not like this. There now exists a diet version
of NATO's cornerstone article 5 agreement between Washington
and DOA. An arrangement several Middle East watchers described
to Axios as unh unprecedented. That does sound unprecedented.
What the dases? Anyway, uh apparently Axio doesn't want to let
me go forward. God damn it. I'll I'll sign in here. Hold on.
Give me a second. Continue on. >> Only way that something
like this happens is if that person had prior knowledge of what
was coming. There is no other explanation for it. So, while everyone
else lost tons of money, some people lost everything. This crash
was so colossal that some people took their own lives because
of it. The only way that someone went totally against the grain
all the way up until one minute before the you know like hold
on just the one minute thing doesn't really make sense or isn't
like
it's not like they knew when the stop was going to happen or
something. It's like they were it it's telling but it's like
they were just probably watching Trump's um truth social, right?
>> Bomb dropped from Trump here is if they knew it was
coming. Like it's just I think it is so clear and the only way
you could >> Yeah. Yeah. It's like >> possibly think
anything else is if you're already brainwashed and mind controlled
and stuck in a cult mentality. I really don't know what it will
take to snap people out of this. The people that are just so
far gone and willing to deny all the evidence of their eyes and
ears that they are constantly being told that they need to following
these orders of just deny everything that you see and hear from
this administration and everything going on. I don't know how
you bring them back into like being able to think, like actually
be able to think. It's terrifying. It's actually extremely scary.
So yeah, I I wanted to yap about this this morning. That's really
about it. So yeah. >> Wow. So a couple people had a problem
with this video. Okay. They just didn't like it at all. One of
those people was >> There's been more drama >> or
if I have to go to Twitch. I don't really want to go to Twitch
to watch it. So Trump actually did it. Trump's pushing for a
third term. It doesn't look like he uploaded to YouTube. So,
I'll have to I'll have to fall back and we'll have to do unfortunately
we'll have to do the Twitch VOD. I hate the Twitch VOD, but we'll
do it. We'll do it. Who cares?
Okay, so Asmin Gold reacting to this. We also had this Tactical
Templar guy is the other video I got for this. Okay, Moist Critical
calls Trump supporters cultists.
Oh my god, can you believe it? Okay, one took over. I just want
you to tell me one to why is it sussy for Qar to do this and
not other places?
Is it Is it just that Qar is doing this as a country transparently
versus
I nothing never mind
>> No, you don't understand. When the other places do it,
they do they do it through US citizens, okay, who just have a
lot of money. It's like way different. So, we're going to be
talking about Moist Critical's latest video called Brainwashing
Situation is Crazy.
And the reason I want to talk about this is very
I don't care that this is a far-left deranged misinformation
hit piece against Trump.
I even don't care that Moist Critical called Trump supporters
cultists in this video
and insulted their intelligence and basically went on this unhinged
rant. I I don't really care. We've seen this sort of thing for
the last 10 years. I don't respect moist critical when it comes
to politics. So why would I give a
>> But here's what I do care about. Here's what actually
offends me about this
>> Oh, what is it going to be? Here's what actually offends
me about this video. What is it going to be? Oh man, I don't
I don't know. What is it actually going to be? Hold on. I'm trying
to think of what would actually offend him about that video.
It's going to be that Charlie did such poor research into so
many things and he's probably going to do the same defense of
it that I did, which is really unfortunate because he might actually
be correct. [__]
>> As this video goes live, do you know where Trump is
right now?
Well, he's >> Oh, it's Dude, he got peace in the Middle
East >> on Air Force One. Do you know where he's
Well, he's currently heading to Israel. >> All of these
people just talk about the things. They just talk about how Trump's
enriched himself by hundreds of millions of dollars and they
don't talk about how he got peace in the Middle East. Why are
you so focused on the corruption that's earned him hundreds of
millions of dollars and not the fact that we have peace between
Gaza and Israel?
Cool. Specifically to Tel Aviv.
Now, why is he doing that? Well, because Trump wants to meet
the hostages
in person. Oh, did I mention that just the other day Trump signed
a peace agreement between Israel and
>> that there is a ceasefire in place and that Israel and
Gaza are no longer fighting for the moment
that the so-called genocide is now over? Trump ended the genocide
that these people have been about for years
even though started it. This isn't even close to the longest.
Like, okay, maybe it's the longest that they've gone without
fighting during this conflict. Although, is it?
Wait, so it was a genocide? Uh, I don't even know. But like,
does this guy understand that
they've been in this situation before that? This probably isn't
like very They've been in this situation before when Palestinians
had a much better leg to stand on. They were nowhere near as
as this before, but they've been at peace like this in similar
situations before and it just ends up getting worse later on.
>> By October 7th,
the fact is that right >> Oh, there's been a there's been
a ceasefire during this. Yeah. Like, show me proof that this
is going to stick.
>> No, there is a ceasefire. Israel is not
is not attacking Israel.
>> There is a ceasefire. Oh, and as part of the first step,
the hostages are being released. These people that have been
in a living hell for the past two years, they are seeing freedom
for the first time. Trump is on his way to greet them in person,
to meet them in person. And what is Moist Critical's video about?
It's basically the greatest hits of far-left debunked propaganda
against
It's debunked, guys. It's just completely it's just propaganda.
Debunked propaganda. >> The typical brain deadad anti-Trump
did. >> Okay. The Qatari base thing. I I don't think Moyes
did great, but obviously I expect no solid answer to the corruption
issues. I expect nothing. >> Dishonest regurgitated for
the first 12 minutes.
And then most critical does mention the ceasefire
for less than 2 minutes in this video and then goes right back
to on Trump. That's my problem with this video. I >> you
are not nice enough to Trump. Have you thought about Have you
said moist critical? Have you said have you even said thank you
to Donald Trump? Moist critical have you even said thank you?
>> Care what Moist Critical's opinion on Trump is? most
critical defense whenever >> I can't believe how JD Vance
did that meme and every person laughed at him and then everybody
like every apparently Republican influencer is like, "Oh no,
that's a really good point." Did Did Zalinsky even say thank
you to Donald Trump? His criticism is I'm not a political commentator,
so why would I take any of his political commentary seriously?
He's a joke. He basically regurgitates anything that Coffeezilla
says anyway. And Coffeezilla is a trumped arrangement that's
been discredited in a thousand different ways, too. So why would
I care about that? Well, I care about that
because of the timing.
We are on the verge of one of the most historic
peace deals in my lifetime where Trump has done something that
everyone said was impossible. They said, "You can't do this.
This is not going to be something that happens." And Trump did
it. Trump got it done.
Biden wouldn't have been able to get this done. Camala Harris
probably would have made it worse by siding with Moss.
I'm being a little bit tongue and
>> uh Okay. Okay, bro.
Definitely. You're Trust me, you're way more accurate than voice
critical. You think Camala Harris supports
amazing >> But she was a cackling. Donald Trump got peace
in Gaza in the Middle East. >> That's his substantive criticism.
Okay, listen. Maybe, maybe I just made that up, but she laughed
like a [__]
Okay, now maybe I totally made that thing about it, but she laughed
like a [__] [__] that [__]
>> That should be the first and last thing in this 20-minute
video is going over how unbelievable this is that people are
not going to be dying as a result of this decision.
There are people who are going to be able to start rebuilding
their lives as a result of this. And my heart is so full for
these people. And then I see a video like this filled with hate
and malice and misinformation and malevolence. And one of the
things that was really interesting was Moist Critical went on
this rant about how Trump has enriched himself. Him and his family
have enriched themselves over this presidency. That is just a
blatant out-and-out lie. Do you know for the vast majority of
Trump's
>> What? Okay,
that's insane, right?
He he went with a blatant lie of Trump enriching himself over
the course of this. Brother
dude, we need to we need actual like analysis of this like how
much Jared Kushner has made. Okay. Al dude, I've got so many
points I want to make at the same time. Okay, there's like so
many things that have happened. Apparently, Qar agreed to a whole
bunch of funding
for US I don't know like just investment in the US. Okay, let's
check this out from May. Uh Trump secures historic 1.2 2 million
$1.2 trillion economic commitment from Qar. Now let's look into
this and see how much can we look at this and just see how much
might have been invested in
I don't know like let's
any companies that Jared Kushner has significant stakes in. Did
Jared Kushner take significant stakes in these companies before
this was invested? Right? Like there's going to be so many cases
like this.
But even just the stuff that's like on its face, tourniquet told
me just a couple weeks ago about a deal where Trump was apparently
was Trump getting stock directly from some company that was doing
a merger where someone in the Trump family was like getting stock
directly like options to buy at like a dollar per share. Is this
a thing that existed? This can't be right. This would have to
be totally fake. Turn, if this sounds familiar, let me know.
Maybe I'm >> First term and in fact during Biden's term,
Trump continuously lost value.
He lost money
always, repeatedly. And by the way, this is something that you
can go and and verify for yourself. I'll just briefly show you
Grock. Grock laid it out. Uh 20 uh 2016 pre-inauguration. He
was
>> bro. I just just so you know, I went and looked at Grock
and Grock perfectly laid out how this works. Okay,
now hold on. He's got a table here. He's going to show the questions
he asked, right? For sure he's going to show the questions he
asked. worth $4.5 billion.
2017 uh early presidency, uh $3.5 billion. Initial drop of $1
billion post inauguration due to lost contracts and market reactions.
Yeah. Basically, people didn't want anything to do with Trump
because the media had spent the better part of a year calling
him a racist and a bigot and a homophobe and he's Oh, he's 2.0.
So, he lost Oh, wait, hold on. 4.5 billion down to 2.3 billion
up to 4.3 billion. Why isn't this next line being 3 billion gain
in the past year alone? driven by crypto is the next line of
this table
that he has cut off from his stream.
Is this a joke?
Hello. You don't understand. Trump actually lost a lot of money
and and here's like a table. Grock laid it out pretty clearly
for me and and and you can't really say much about it. Are you
ser is this guy serious? That's incredible. Lost >> a lot
of >> He has to He has to acknowledge that, right? He has
to talk about that. There's no way he could get through this
without talking about it. Also, >> contracts, the left
was raging. >> They were very upset. Brands didn't want
anything to do with Trump because they were afraid that they
were going to get burned down or attacked by far-left
>> Then Trump continues to lose money. And it says 3.1
billion to 2.1 billion. And as you see as the years go on, he
basically just continuously loses money
>> So hold on. His counter to Trump has enriched himself
at historic levels. He has totally gone. He's like broken every
norm. Okay. He's enriched himself massively. Your response is,
"Well, he only did it between 2024 and 2025.
He only did it in the past year." Yeah, that's the problem, idiot.
Reminder, this is the guy who got techone to Christianity. Okay.
Yeah. Teone. Teone could be talked into anything by anybody.
Okay?
He could be talked into anything by anyone. He is a complete
[__] >> till October 2025. Now, two things
happened. One, Trump
made True Social and the revenue that he got from that, the the
money that he got from that was about $3 billion. It was estimated
about $3 billion and Trump coined. He got a bunch of money.
But the idea that Trump had been making
>> Wait, does this guy not understand that like basically
him Trump having control over crypto regulation is what allowed
him to do >> money hand over fist during his presidency
is a lie. It is an out and out lie. And by the way, >> no
it's not. No, it's not. This Trump coin was a rug pull, dude.
>> Wait, let me just mention something, Charlie, because
you omitted it in your video because you were too busy ranting
about Trump.
Trump was nearly assassinated
twice. Three times >> So wait, what what point is this
supposed to drive?
>> Answer for the corruption.
Answer for
I mean just the corruption and self enriching himself. How do
how does anything around his assassination attempt have anything
to do with him enriching himself? Unless you're just going to
make the argument that he should be allowed to do it. Trump had
well I mean New York, Florida, all of these different broken
criminal corrupt left-wing DAs and judges going after him as
he was trying to run for president. He was investigated by the
FBI. They made up charges for him. I like this is one of the
most clearcut cases of lawfare that I've ever >> What part
of those charges were made up? Seen this man went through absolute
hell to get where he is?
You don't think there was an easier way for him to make money?
You greasy imbecile. You low IQ crowd shut in. Dude, we think
that there's this guy is honestly here just I want you to just
picture the kind of person who's going to go on a YouTube video,
put their credibility on the line, okay, 26,000 subscribers,
and say, "Don't you think there was an easier way for Trump to
make billions of dollars than a crypto rug pull? You really think
a crypto rugpole is like the easiest way to make money? Yes.
Objectively, it is like the easiest way to make money in all
of human history.
Yes. Yeah. That's that's literally the easiest way to make money
in the entirety of human history. There's a crypto rugpole. Congratulations.
You found it. Yes.
And and then insider trading apparently like with regards to
the eth with regards to all the other stuff going on. Um, I wouldn't
even say just insider trading, just outnote corruption. Him enriching
himself by what did he he basically put all of his um
like the Secret Service has to go to Mara Lago to stay when he
lives there, right? When he's like there during his presidency
and he would charge them out the app for all of that stuff. And
basically, this guy's basically
using a bunch of different excuses that are almost equivalent
to, "Oh my god, Trump did give up his salary. He's like he's
such a good guy. this this what he's doing right now. Like the
exact thing that Charlie mocked is the thing this guy is going
to do repeatedly. Like he is
he is maybe the best example of cultist that Charlie could have
asked for. I assume Asmin Gold will do this with a lot more finesse,
a lot more um precision. This is very embarrassing. >> Germaphobe
freak. You don't think there would be an easier way to make money
and your biggest point of contention is that Trump sells merchandise
that you particularly don't like? Don't you sell soap, Charlie?
Don't you sell like cheeky soap and you're going to berate Trump
because >> he's the president of the United States. He's
the president of the United States.
He's not the same as other citizens. >> He sells cologne.
Like Trump sells cologne and hats and towels and stuff from like
his days working in the field of the resort. Like you're really
going to get pissed about that? He's selling Trump towels and
Trump watches and stuff. You sell cheeky soap. What do you know
about comic books, Charlie? You decided to release a comic book,
Godfist. What the do you know about comic books? You've never
made a comic book before,
but you have the money. Okay. Uh, is comic production highly
regulated by the
And is there a way through deception or market manipulation to
make significantly more money from a comic than you otherwise
would?
this guy, he's comparing insider trading or a rugpull or I guess
with with the Trump coin tourniquets telling me they did the
liquidity pool fee scam so they just increase the fees massively
like they they charge massive fees. Basically, Trump just did
the same thing that the Hawkua girl did on like just another
level, an entirely other level. Okay,
I'm sure a lot of conservatives were pissed about the Hakua girl.
They keep that same energy for Trump when he did >> and
he said this is what I want to do and then you did it. But you're
going to berate Trump for that. And this whole thing is ridiculous.
Why are we talking about this [__] that's been debunked
a thousand times? As opposed to talking about Trump's historic
and monumental
Trump was able to bring peace to the Middle East. Honestly,
I I I mean, I hate to say it, okay, cuz it's going to sound like
kind of,
but I think I legitimately think Trump's plan for the Middle
East was
Guys, you don't understand. If you stop this right now, it's
going to buy me so much political capital. We're going to be
able to make sure that like eight generations from now, our our
children, our grand our great great great great grandchildren
will still be eating like kings. Okay? There's so many ways we
can enrich ourselves. If you just stop fighting right now, you
don't understand. Okay? We're open for business. We're going
to we're doing all the corruption. You come here to the US, you
invest here, we'll invest back in you, we'll own all of the [__]
we're investing in. It'll be insane how much money we make. Okay?
It'll be insane. Just stop the fighting. We could we could actually
secure the bag for every one of us. All right.
That's that's what I feel this deal is purely. All right. And
yet we're sitting here talking about how Trump Trump fans are
cultist because they don't agree with me. They don't agree with
me. Hey guys, Moy Critical here. Man, could you believe that
these Trump supporters are cultist because they don't agree with
me about Trump? Now, let me tell you all the misinformation
>> you're defending. This guy's just defending scamming
Trump followers for money and saying that's not cultlike. I like
it when my guy does a crypto scam. I like it when my guy does
that. Okay.
I still Yeah. Yeah. My Trump coin has lost like $100,000. I've
lost my life savings. But uh you know what? We got peace in the
Middle East. At least we got peace in Israel. Why would I complain
about him taking my life savings when
when we have peace in the Middle East now? >> That I heard
from Coffeezilla. Let me regurgitate it as if it's all my own
Charlie, this was an embarrassing video. It was absolutely pathetic.
It was beneath you to make. And honestly, I don't know if you
got the DM from Hassan. I don't know if it was because you watched
copies of his video and you were just so >> Did you get
Charlie? Did you get the call from Hassan?
Are you Are you operating on a communist >> Angry. You
got Oh. Oh, good. This Trump is so bad. He He's selling merch
just like me. But when he does it, it's bad. I I don't know what
your deal is, but this was a humiliating video for you. It was
deranged and the timing of it could not be worse because Trump
is currently on his way to stop a genocide, as you put it. You
call Benjamin Netanyahu a genocidal freak.
Right now, the Palestinians and the Israelis are cheering Donald
Trump. They are so happy that he ended this. But like, hold on.
If it was literally just merch, like shitty merch, like cologne
and [__] I could probably let that go. It's bad for
the president to have major interests in any business because
it is a conflict of interest and that office has more power than
any other office on planet earth and he's increase the power
of that office every step of the way. Okay, so those are all
problems
but I could stomach that. It's like on top of that he's also
got to do every possible scam. He's got to engage in every other
type of corruption he possibly can to increase his net worth
in the meantime. That's the problem. That's the real problem.
But apparently you're not happy. You're mad. You're very mad
at him. Why? He sold cologne.
And oh well, he made money. There's insider training. Do you
have any evidence of that? No. Of course you don't. Of course
you have no evidence that Trump is calling his friends. All right,
guys. All right. Look, I'm going to be raising the tariffs on
China.
I'm going to be raising the tariffs on China. So short the stocks.
It's just ridiculous.
This is the sort of we have to hate. >> All right. Look,
I'm going to be raising the tariffs on China.
I'm going to be raising the tariffs on China. So, short the stocks.
It's just ridiculous.
This is the sort of [__] we have to do. >> Why
is it ridiculous? >> Trump is a phenomenal president. >> He's
so much better than Biden that honestly it hurts my brain to
think that we elected that corpse into >> like
how do you challenge Charlie? Okay, I'm going have to go back
because I have to hear what he said here precisely, but he's
literally challenging Charlie on saying MAGA people are like
cultists. And your only argument you've presented so far is uh
we got peace in the Middle East, so he should be allowed to steal.
He should be allowed to do like corrupt like fraudulent because
we got peace in the Middle East. That's the argument of that.
No, of course you don't. Of course you have no evidence that
Trump was calling his friends. All right, guys. All right, look.
I'm going to be raising the tariffs on China.
I'm going to be >> How does this guy think that the SEC
finds trades that they they suspect are insider trading? How
does he think the SEC goes about doing that? Some of the simplest,
easiest, most understandable pattern matching that happens on
the entire planet Earth. Okay, you look for trades that don't
make sense in the current market conditions that happen to be
like based on basically it's like some miracle trade where this
guy decided to risk like $50 million on well not even 50. This
these people put what 30 and 80 million in but like it's usually
not 50. It's like oh like a million $1.5 million on some bet
that returns like 10 to1 100 to1 with no reason no impetus for
making that bet. Right? It's the exact thing that happened here.
That's how people go and find trades that they want to
Hold on a second. What are you linking me here? Tourniquette.
What is this now?
Oh, this is about your World Liberty Finance, right? Okay. Okay.
All right. All right. We could take a We could take a look at
Wait, Zach Wickoff.
Surely that wouldn't this wouldn't be Steve Wickoff like this
wouldn't be Steve Wickoff like
emissary to Israel. Steve Wickoff. There's no way. There's no
way. Oh, please tell me this is not son. This isn't son, right?
Tourniquette, that's not son. Hold on. Hold on. No, no, that's
not who that is. That's not who that is. That's not possible
that that's who that is. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. I'm
asking a different question. You're misunderstanding me. Company.
I need to go to their website here. Give me a second. About Okay.
No.
I'm I didn't understand. I miss I I didn't recognize it. I thought
this was uh Justin's son for a second. That's who it looked like
to me for a second, but cool.
All right, we'll we'll look into this in just a little bit.
Yeah, I did a little bit of racism there. I thought that's who
that I was like, no way. That's fine. You're raising potatoes
on China, so short the stocks.
It's just ridiculous.
This is the sort of [__] we have to deal with. Trump
is a phenomenal president. He's so much better than Biden that
honestly it hurts my brain to think that we elected that corpse
into office. But for Moyes Critical or anyone else to sit there
and make a video like this that is so pathetic, so dishonest,
so deranged, so riddled with misinformation on the precipice
of >> He hasn't even said what he thinks the misinformation
is yet, has he? He's basically just gone, you haven't said thank
you to Trump for the good things he's done. He's not actually
said what the misinformation is. He's just saying you haven't
thanked Trump for the good things he's done yet. Well, maybe
maybe I mean, not maybe anything. He just hasn't addressed the
actual commentary. >> This incredible moment
>> and for you to take 11 minutes to vent your nonsense
and then just put in like a minute of oh yeah again there's a
ceasefire and then back to shooting on Trump.
This whole video should have been about the ceasefire and how
amazing it is. Lives are going to be saved. Charlie is it that
you don't think that Trump deserves the credit because Benjamin
Netanyahu himself said that Trump deserves a Nobel Peace Prize
for this.
Everyone involved has said that Trump was instrumental in this.
So I don't know what your malfunction is. I don't know why you
were so brain broken about
Everything that you brought up is either halftruths, misinformation.
>> Why Why didn't you Why didn't you
thank Donald Trump for this for the ceasefire? Why didn't you
thank him? Benjamin Netanyahu says he deserves a Nobel Peace
Prize. Why? Why haven't you thanked him yet? You're just complaining
about the bad things he's done. You won't even acknowledge the
good things.
>> It's like dude, he's actually doing the argument. Okay,
he's doing this argument. Yeah, like like sure this like Epstein
ripped some kids, but have you seen how much money he earned
for other billionaires? He does so much good. Why would you look
at him kids? Why would you look at the bad things?
He's just he's arguing we don't look at all of the egregious
ethics violations of the Trump administration so far because
he's in the Middle East.
He what he saves. It's the it's the Cosby bit. Okay. It's the
Dave Chappelle Cosby bit. He what he saves or just out and out
propaganda. You need to get better information if you're going
to be talking about politics.
It's not good enough that you just went and saw something that
Coffeezilla said because all I had to do was go to Grock and
it's abundantly clear that you're full of Trump did not make
all this money during his first term. Man, he was so rich. Oh,
man. He like quadrupled the money he made in his first term.
No, he didn't. He lost money every Oh, wait. Did Charlie say
Hold on. Maybe that is a thing. Maybe I just wasn't paying attention
to that very specific claim or something. Hold on. Moist critical.
Moist critical cope.
Moist critical
brainwash growing up. >> Hold on. Let's see. Let's see
if there's a first term reference. Is there a first term reference?
First
term. First
term in enrich >> American people to buy solely to enrich
himself and his family. His meme coin and all of that. His family
is going ballistic in terms of how much money they're making
off of his presidency. They're not even hiding it. They are just
constantly making money off of you. As you suffer and get less
and less money, they get more and more. They are taking the >> No,
no, no. Hold on. We thought We thought that We thought that he
was saying this. I don't think I don't think that's true. I don't
think Charlie even said this. I can't find it in here. Hold on.
Quadruple
triple
net worth.
Net worth is one word. No. Oh, hold on. Trump and his Trump's
family. Okay, hold on. Trump and Trump's family's net worth has
exploded since becoming president. How do you defend that? Well,
I'll tell you how. Because they say Trump is >> Ah,
that's what it's going to be. I see.
Yeah, it's obvious Charlie's talking about the second term, but
this guy's going since he became president. Oh, I'll I'll push
it back to the first term. That's how I'll That's how I'll counter
this. It still doesn't matter because Trump's net worth has exploded,
right? It has absolutely exploded. But the the second term in
terms of corruption is way different than the first term. Like
obviously he didn't have the the death grip on his party that
he had in the first term every single year
because the left is an unhinged deranged terrorist group that
masquerades as a political party and made Trump's brand toxic
because they would attack anyone that did business with him.
Anyway, brothers, I'm not going to take much more of your time,
but I'm hon >> uh that's true. By the way, in uh in 2018,
I went to the International in Vancouver. Okay. I stayed at the
Trump Hotel. I got a room that should have been like four or
500 bucks. It was like the nicest room I ever stayed in for like
a hundred bucks a night. Okay. Cuz nobody wanted to stay in the
Trump
And I got Dude, it was crazy. I got it like at a time that should
have been vacant, too. I got like such an insanely good deal.
Like I I only went and booked a hotel like a couple weeks maybe
like two weeks before I went. Maybe a week before I went actually.
I I booked that hotel so late.
Yeah. So I know that his his brand was like totally toxic. I
didn't give a [__] >> Honestly disappointed
in Mo Critical. And by the way, let actually let me let me end
on something positive. Okay.
Let me end on something positive about Moist Critical. This was
a pretty harsh video towards Moist.
And I don't like Moist. I don't I don't think he's a particularly
good person. I think that he puts on a facade, but a lot of his
leftwing policies lead to making immoral and absolutely indefensible
uh policy positions that he would be okay with. He affirms the
LGBTQ. He affirms the transitioning of kids, even though he walked
that back. That's initially what was on his brain, that that
would be perfectly fine,
which I don't >> Okay, Sneo won. Sneak one on that one.
>> I don't think that transitioning people at all is okay.
I think that that is a form of mental illness that should be
treated with compassion, but it should be regarded as mental
illness, not affirmed.
You wouldn't say, "Oh, well, you're 18, so your schizophrenia
is totally normal, and we're going to affirm." Yes, that is a
a snake that's breathing fire in front of >> this guy is
stuck in 2015 or 2016, isn't >> This is like this guy is
actually transmitting from like a time rift where he is he is
stuck perpetually in the year 2017. He cannot escape it. He'll
be stuck there forever. He'll be doing content from there forever.
Okay,
>> no. No, absolutely [__] not. But what I
will say is I do admire the fact that Moist critical is slightly
different than other content creators in that he was willing
to criticize Hassan for Hassan shocking his dog, which by the
way, let me play real quick just to refresh your memory in case
some of you hadn't seen the clip. I don't know how, but uh Hassan
did shock his dog live on >> of America. >> Just
so you guys remember, Huzz is much more consequential
violence. Okay, it's the same reason as to why America Ka, please
just go. Just stop, >> dude. No way. >> Yeah, Hassan
has a history of abusing his dog. More and more clips are coming
to light. This guy should absolutely be in jail. I mean,
Guys, Hassan,
listen. He pulled Fish's tail. And I think if you've pulled a
dog's tail, you must go to jail. You pull the tail, you go to
jail. And them's the brakes because it rhymes. All right. What
a demented monster this guy is. What a pathetic pugid monster.
Anyway, um yeah, I think that most critical calling him out,
even if it was in a very gentle and soft way, I think that shows
a spine. That's something that Lwig would never do. So, I think
that's a huge win. Uh on top of that, Moist Critical did say
he was turning off super chats and memberships and he is a multi-millionaire.
So, I think that is a pretty cool thing. Moist Critical will
make money off of ad revenue and his businesses and stuff. And
I think that's great that he's like, "You know what? I don't
need money from people that make probably like 30 to 40. >> Okay,
guys. I am not in the Charlie situation. I am in a very different
situation. We've got an hour left on the stream. So, I'm going
to take this time to say if you like the content, go ahead, follow
on every platform. There's
Uh, both of those places you should follow. Okay, there's the
Discord.
You can buy a TTS message through either of the links provided
by Maximus just now. the Streamlabs link, the Kickbot link. Okay,
you can buy a TTS message if you want. You could sub on Kick,
you give subs on Kick. Love individual subs on Kick because they're
a nice monthly rolling income for me that I can plan all my bills
around. Okay, if you don't have an individual sub, I'd appreciate
you getting one. If you do have an individual sub, go ahead,
give some subs. Every dollar you spend goes towards more time
on the streams.
Okay, so we're at 58 minutes right now. We are 11 subs from two
more hours on the stream. I'd probably do what? Five subs for
another hour. We could do 30 each.
Yeah. So guys, go ahead, sub. Buy a TTS message. Add more time
to the stream. Appreciate all of you. That'll be the end of the
show. All right. I'm not like most critical. I can't shut off
memberships and everything else. Uh there's also Patreon. patreon.com/jok
as Maximus just threw in there. Thank you. >> $4,000 a
year. I don't need them to pay me like $100 or whatever to like
have an interaction on stream. I think that's pretty cool. I
do. And there are some takes that Moist Critical have that I
has that I do agree with. Like the Pokemon
uh you know the Pokemon trading card fights. I mean that is good
content that he does. I think the problem is that when Moyes
critical dips his toe into politics he's a [__]
and he's out of his depth. I think that Moyes Critical and this
is honest feedback. This is honest honest feedback. Moyes Critical
should stay out of politics.
He doesn't have the stomach for it. He doesn't have the brains
for it. He doesn't have the character for it because every time
he talks about politics, he kneejerks into these far-left positions
that are just objectively wrong, both morally and intellectually
and factually. Anyway, brothers, that's going to do it for today's
video. I want to thank you for watching. I want to thank you
for supporting the channel. And you know what? Go show Moto some
love. Yeah, that's right. Go show him some love. No, that's not
a euphemism. Go show him some
You know what
>> the Bible says to pray for your enemies. And I I don't
consider most critical an enemy. I just consider him wrong on
this issue. Go show him some support. Have a great day. >> Wow.
Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow.
All right. Okay. We're going from there. I'm going to pull up
the Asmin Gold stuff, but
uh tourniquet also wants me to look at what caused the liquidation,
the F liquidation. Vancouver Trump Hotel is a junky camp now.
Bro, it was uh pretty dicey. I thought I was going to get robbed
outside the airport. I got sent from like the airport to that
place. I asked somebody and they looked at me for money and I'm
like, "Bro, I ain't got no money." The
Okay, tourniquet wants me to look at how the liquidation happened
for the F stuff. How did the liquidation happen? Two actual catalysts
for the crypto collapse. It was not the not including the ch
the tariff tweet. Hold on.
Should I take a picture of this or something? Give me a second.
I'm I'm going to read this really quickly just so I can uh try
to process. All right, give me a second.
Follows a lot of this stuff. Let me see
to actual catalyst for the crypto collapse, not including the
tariff tweet. Binance said some API access issue that made it
so their internal users uh users orders and API calls took priority
over external API calls. Uhhuh. Yeah, Binance. That's shocking.
Definitely. I would totally trust that Binance had this issue
and Binance didn't just like steal a bunch of people's money,
bro. Bruh. Dude.
Oh my god. Binance does this all the time, guys. Guys, I know.
I Yeah, CZ is crazy. All right, CZ be doing [__]
like this
all the time, guys. We We had like some unreliability. We had
like a crash during um you know, the the prices were crashing.
We had a crash. Somehow none of you could could exit your positions.
I'm sorry that that happened. Please know it'll never happen
again for the hundth time.
This caused liquidity to dry up pretty quickly on many altcoin
order books that normally rely on those API calls to keep those
alts liquid. Many dropped as much as 50, 70, even 90% very quickly
as a result, demonstrated by very tall and thin candle wicks.
Sure, this was the primary catalyst for all the liquidations
that happened following the cascading event. Cautious Binance
users naturally began panic selling their pegged stable coin
holdings, USDE,
so anything that was on one of these networks. Uh we've seen
this in a few cases in the past where USDT and USDC I Oh, so
the they deped probably pretty hard that massive amounts of selling
pressure and lack of liquidity
caused uh the I guess the stable coins prices to to dep from
$1. These these coins are basically supposed to be backed by
actual cash reserves that if you were willing to go through like
a slow process, you could trade your coins for dollars directly,
right? And so these should never dep from $1. They should always
be worth $1. And apparently these things, it's like the dollar
crashing down to 65 cents temporarily.
This is an AI post you're reading. No. Well, I don't think so.
Turn is saying he wrote this or tournicate. He might have used
AI to research it. It all makes sense though.
Uh following the cascading event, cautious Binance users naturally
began panic selling their pegged stable coin holdings. Oh, sorry.
Sure. We already read that part. Uh so 65 cents crazy drop.
Tether dropped to 88 cents during FTX. Yeah, but weaker ones
tourniquet like weaker ones that weren't just USDT.
I think like the Tronbacked one, I can't remember what it's called.
I think that one dropped to like 65 cents. Oh, sure, sure. It's
just a summary. All right. With everything that proceeded and
just naturally based on their sheer market cap, most of the only
remaining leverage positions with those in BTC and F by this
point,
wait, hold on. With everything that preceded, most of the only
remaining leverage positions were those in oh, the only things
that hadn't been liquidated were positions in Bitcoin and F.
Binance had been under an 8day scheduled update window where
they were rolling out an update to their system that would cease
their collateral asset pricing from their own internal pricing
for stable coins like
USDF I'm guessing wrapped
wrapped ETH and binary soul and instead use external price oracles.
I feel like you definitely know what that means. So instead of
getting um instead of just using their own order books, they
would go look at some external or oracle for a price where it
would probably include multiple different liquidity pools and
it wouldn't automatically offer really low prices just because
your liquidity was bad.
So
essentially what they're saying is you normally you have an order
book and it's an actual market where the price is derived based
on what people will buy and sell for, right? that has the issue
of if you get low liquidity is in if not a lot of people are
buying or selling on one side then the buy pressure or sell pressure
can force the price to fluctuate in a different direct in like
a direction that isn't representative of universal market demand
for those things. And so using the external price oracle you
could keep the price at a certain point and make sure certain
users aren't getting screwed over or just that you're like reflecting
the natural price for most places instead of um instead of just
in your own order
So traders who used those stables as collateral for their leverage,
perpetual B, Bitcoin, and F positions were liquidated instantly
as Binance's internal oracle recalculated collateral values to
be much lower than they would be. So as the collateral crashed,
as the you know, let's say you put um this USD in, right? Was
that the one that went to Yeah, USDE lost, you know, 45% of its
value. So imagine that your leverage position that you had set
up the the collateral you're putting to get the leverage, right?
You're basically providing collateral. So they give you a loan
and then if your position goes below a certain point, they cash
in your loan because you can no longer cover, right? So your
loan just lost 45% of its value instantly or very quickly. That
means you're probably getting liquidated not because the price
of Bitcoin went down, but because the price of your stable coin,
your leverage asset went
traders who use those stables as collateral. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. This liquidation event will was still only representative
of a smallest number of people trading leveraged Bitcoin and
ETH positions because most of those are still currently collateralized
with Ether and USDC. USDC. Why? Why do I feel like I saying that
wrong? USDC.
USDC which had which had no issues. Okay. Jesus. All right. Both
affected groups suffered losses due to two separate Binance infrastructure
failures and warrant compensation accordingly. Binance put out
a statement that essentially takes responsibility for event number
two, but not event number one, which was the real liquidation
event. But at the end of the day, the issue would have been far
less of a mass casualty event if not for Trump's tariff tweet.
So my argument is that the whale that shorted was doing it on
insider information, but I had no idea that this was going to
have the type of effect it did because of Binance uh because
of the Binance issue exacerbate exacerbating it exponentially.
I kind of wondered if um
I kind of wondered if Yeah, basically they were expecting to
make like like a million dollars, right? Like they're trying
to make a million dollars and they end up making $190 and they're
like, "Oh, me."
Binance already announced they're going to refund $283 million,
but that's pennies at this point. Ah, I see.
Jesus. All right. Interesting.
Okay. Okay, now that we've
now that we've things good and dead, that's interesting if that's
what happened. Um, so basically it wasn't really the tariff tweet
or the tariff tweet is the reason the crypto market, sorry, the
Binance situation is why the crypto market got so but the tariff
tweet is what caused every market to get and both compounded.
Okay, got it. Got it. Got it. Got it. Got it. All right. Now,
we're going to watch the uh the Asmin Gold stuff on this. Asmin
Gold decided to watch the Charlie video as well, and I I can't
imagine how he's going to try to defend. I >> I don't know
if it's going to be Metal Gear. I'm pretty sure it's not. I have
no idea. Pre-watch? No, not necessarily. Sometimes it just does
that on my
If I actually intended to pre-watch something, I would be watching
it on my TV or I'd watch it on incognito mode if you want me
to be honest. But no, I have not. Um, okay. So, this has been
a very, very, very controversial video. Uh, I don't necessarily
know why. My understanding is that it has like politics in it,
but we'll see what
Okay, buddy.
Guys, I didn't pre-watch this. I understand it might have politics
in it, so let's give it a >> Oh, that's right. Yes. Yesterday
I skimmed the video and I saw it was the crypto thing at the
end. That's how I Yeah, that's how it's there. >> Yeah,
you just skimmed it. Okay. >> I remember growing up >> Oops,
just a second. I remember growing up thinking that brainwashing
and mind control was just something you >> I guess that's
that might be true. You can get a good idea of what a video is
about just from like asking people about it, which is what I
did with this video. I just I'd heard that this video is quite
uh it's quite a big step for most critical. It doesn't usually
take actual stances on anything >> seeing comic books and
cartoons.
>> Now I know it's a very real thing that you can see happening
daily in this country. Now, the big thing I want to talk about,
I'm going to talk about a lot here. >> People have lost
their minds. >> A bunch of blabber in here and duel coming
out of my mouth as I'm spitting because I'm about to be getting
pretty
>> The big focus is on the huge crypto collapse uh from
yesterday.
and the very suspicious, very lucky trader who was able to cash
out $190 million off of it because they were shorting Bitcoin
and Ethereum a day before and all the way up until a minute before
Trump's truth social post announcing the massive tariffs on China,
which crashed the >> wow
the entire market. Damn. >> And 30 minutes later, they
cash out 190.
it did Asmin There's no way Asmin Gold was unaware of that, right?
He had to have watched the Coffeezilla video as >> Million
dollar. It seems like they might have known something, but that
>> Wait, what was he what was he even reacting to? There
>> can't be, right? That would be corruption. And this
administration doesn't engage in that kind of nefarious
>> except for all the previous times that this exact same
thing has happened with Trump announcing things on Truth Social
that people close to him that suckle his teeth must have had
insider knowledge on because they're able to cash out millions
upon millions of dollars because of his rinse and repeat cycle
of threatening tariffs.
Oh man, Asmin Gold's gonna it's going to be something like this,
right? I already I can already tell. Okay, now I had Did I have
a way to pre-watch this or was this happening during my stream?
I don't know if I had a way to pre-watch this, but
listen, I can already tell what the take is going to be. It's
going to be something like, listen, maybe you guys should be
thinking about how people might know about this corruption and
still want to vote for Trump. Did you think about that? Did you
think about how like maybe people just would rather have a corrupt
president who's going to cut down on immigration and stop foreign
wars than they care about a president who's not maybe he deserves
that money. He's never going to say that. He won't say that one.
Okay. But it will be the line of attack of like, have you thought
about why people will support somebody who's openly corrupt?
Have you thought about like maybe people just really don't like
immigration that much? It's going to be that whole thing. I I
can tell Gold can just [__] on Trump. He's not hitched
to Trump. No, no, no, no, no. He's he'll on like the open corruption,
but he will he will defend Trump like being voted for and he
will defend basically he'll defend people from saying that uh
he'll defend I guess MAGA people from being called cultists.
I think so. >> Backing off tariffs, postponing tariffs,
just fluctuating the market up and down. Yet people in his inner
circle must be privy to this knowledge because they are making
absolute bullseye trades based on that before it becomes >> I
think that I think Charlie's right about this and and I I think
this is a meta level problem.
I think that anybody who's involved in government needs to be
barred from making any trades or having anything to do with political
trading whatso or sorry stock trading or uh crypto trading or
anything like this. And this is like a meadow level issue. >> Sure.
I think you should just be in the market, right? The market.
>> This is a Nancy Pelosi. This is a uh you know any of
the uh like a
Barack Obama, Hillary Clinton.
>> Okay. Interesting. He didn't go to the Trump defense
route. He didn't go No. You Why would you say that, Zy? Have
you never watched an Asmin Gold video before? Do you think you
become the most popular grifter on the entire internet? by just
out and out saying you're grifting like right off the bat, like
making it clear immediately. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. There's It's way more
finesse than that. Okay, you can't just you can't just say, "Well,
Trump can't do anything wrong or else you prove Charlie correct,
right?"
He can't do it. So, just wait. Just wait and we'll see what what
actually happens. Okay? Anybody I would say this with, this is
this is a huge issue.
They should not even be able to own stock.
It's such a massive conflict of interest. And maybe they're >> So
that naturally would continue on to owning your own business,
right? There he can't have any problem with with Charlie's criticism
that Trump didn't place any of his [__] in a blind
trust. Obviously having control of these businesses, having them
still in your name, that's that's a conflict of interest, too.
>> They're immediate family. Maybe you're right.
Maybe you're right. I I don't know if I'd go that far. I probably
would, but one thing I'm certain about is they they themselves
should not be doing it and their family shouldn't be doing sorry,
their their spouse should not be doing it either. Then they would
just leak information to somebody else. Yeah. Yeah. But they
definitely shouldn't be able to. >> Yeah. But having that
level of indirection, having that like those links there, that's
how you figure out people are doing it. So you do you do want
to force that level of like, oh, they have to introduce a third
party or >> Why do politicians get off the hook? I I don't
know. But yeah, I agree with this. I this has been a problem
for years >> public. So this isn't really anything new.
It's just the most egregious instance because you can literally
see it. This account opens and starts shorting Bitcoin and Ethereum
a day before this announcement and then a minute before >> it's
like it's like somebody you you give somebody their math your
your math test and you're like, "Okay, copy it, but don't make
it look at obvious." And they just go one one for one. That's
it. >> The truth social post goes live. Yeah. Like it's
it's unbelievable. And if you are a MAGA cultist, it actually
is unbelievable. They refuse to believe it. They refuse to accept
the very real reality that they are getting hosed.
>> it's very likely that somebody that was involved with
Trump's administration made this decision
or somebody that's privy to knowledge that they shouldn't be
aware of made this decision. And I think that there should be
an investigation into who did that and making sure that that
person never has access to information again and potentially
also criminal charges >> and take all their money from
them. >> Baron Trump. Well, I don't know. Nobody
Like I And this is something that I feel like I I I've always
felt this way. This isn't a like this isn't a Trump maga cultist
opinion. This is a meta level problem that's affected politics
for years. And Trump's family's net worth has exploded since
becoming president. How do you defend that? Well, I'll tell you
how. Because they say Trump is such a benevolent saint. He actually
doesn't even keep his salary from being president. Wow. That's
how much he cares about the American people.
>> You delusional homunculus. >> The presidential
salary is actual peanuts. It's literal condoms in the grand scheme
of how much money him and his family are making throughout his
presidency. when he was being sworn in, he was still launching
up to 168 new products. And that doesn't even >> No, no.
While he's in office, he was doing the Trump phone.
He did. He did the Trump phone. >> Include things like
his cologne that he >> Whatever happened with the Trump
phone, by the way? Yeah. Whatever happened with this? Like, are
we going to get those or
Trump watches.
He didn't. His family did. Well, when are they going to do it?
>> Trump Guccalore smell, the Trump watches, the Trump
phone and [__] like that. So, that is only increased
the amount of things that he is hawking to the American people
to buy solely to enrich himself and his family, his [__]
meme coin and all of that. His
putting his memecoin and world liberty financial, a crypto company
started by the his family and that of Steve Wickoff, his Middle
East hung >> family. I think that the memecoin is indefensible.
Uh, the meme coin was definitely bad. Uh, I I don't see how anybody
can spin it. >> See, this is why, by the way, this is why
Asmin Gold is the best of the the Grifters, right? It's why he's
like totally unstoppable. It's why he's he's winning in every
possible situation every single time cuz he's willing to go and
say like for the obvious bad, I can just go and say like it's
bad and I denounce Trump for it and it has no effect on anything
and then I keep going. Right. whole bunch of other Trump people,
they're they're not as big as he is, right? They're really scared
of people pulling away from them. They can't do it. But as gets
to sit there, he's got this benefit of this massive audience
behind him. He just gets to go, "No, obviously that's bad." So
he doesn't have to look totally delusional all the time as not
being bad. And especially when Melania Trump did the same thing.
I mean, really, it was bad. I mean, I I don't there's a big problem
that I think a lot of people have where they can't like this
is somebody like I mean I'm generally like pretty pro Trump,
>> I mean, he's denouncing right now. He's literally saying
that the meme coins
>> Agreed with a lot of things he's done. Not everything,
but a lot of things he's done. Like, for example, the Middle
East stuff. I've been glazing him for like the last hour about
that. Right. But this definitely was a bad decision. And I think
that a lot of people have this fixation in their mind that they're
allergic to any degree of nuance or complexity to any issue.
And I think that this aversion has caused them to delude themselves
to a degree that's unhealthy. And so what's happened is that
people will always try to come up with excuses for why something
bad happens on their side. But the reality is that sometimes
people that you agree with can do things that are wrong. And
that doesn't mean that the people that you agree with that are
doing it are are evil like in all cases. I mean, people are complex.
There's good and bad things that people do. But trying to force
every single person into being like this black and white cookie
cutter thing because you're afraid of dealing with the nuance
of the human condition is just simply setting yourself up to
fail. It's your your abil.
God damn it.
I thought maybe I thought maybe he would go the same way as some
of his drones had and that's just not happening.
Unlucky.
He's He's This is why he's uh so effective. He's nailing the
response, right? He's he is just saying that like, hey, by by
the way, he's still humanizing along the way. He's still going,
"Yeah, you have to call it bad." He's not calling for anything
to be done that's going to happen, right? Why is he sounding
smart right now? He's uh hold on. It's be because he is smart,
but the thing he's doing is probably still pretty gross, right?
Like
he will never he will never have a breaking point from these
issues
after which he will say, "Okay, this is it." Like he will not
have a breaking point. He will never go, "Okay, well, I can't
keep going. I can't rock with these guys. I can't give them credit
for it." Right? He is willing to go and say, "No, no, no. We
have he is he is doing exactly what I said, but in a smarter
way even, right? He's not saying whether he would denounce or
not. He's not saying like, "Oh, well, why do you why do you think
people are okay with this?" He's saying,
"No, this is bad." And like I really like the other stuff he
was doing, right? He leaves it like open. He's not actually he's
not recommending any action. He's not saying you have to do anything.
He's just going, "Oh, Trump Trump good and Trump bad." But
at least for politics, you should have some level of you should
have some level of ethical bedrock that you don't drop below.
You have to have a level of ethical bedrock that you stay above
or else you're not responsible enough to be in those positions.
Cuz guess what? Trump's up a lot of things, too. The tariffs
are universally decrieded by like everybody. He's destroying
the economy, right? You cannot make the argument that at least
for Americans or or North Americans or anybody in the West that
this guy is a better president than the that he's good enough
that you could just ignore the corruption. Okay? Not even with
peace in the Middle East if that were to stick, which it hasn't
yet. So, it's weird to just give him morals for that. Building
a web of lies. You're lying to yourself. You're lying to everybody
around you and you're just being delusional. And I don't know
why people do this. I really don't. I think this is a and I you
know I'll probably say this a lot. It seems like it's one of these
videos, right? This is a this is a both sides issue, right? So
I I think that people constantly try to look up for excuses for
why their side does something, but when the other side does it,
it's bad. And I think this is a massive issue overall.
This could all be true. Yeah. Yeah, it is. It's all or nothing
thinking.
>> This is Tim Pier slop. No, it's not.
You understand? If we go watch Tim Pool, if we were to watch
Tim P respond to this, Tim P would absolutely hardcore defend
Trump on a bunch of stuff, he would totally defend like I feel
like he would border he would get close to defending the crypto
stuff. I don't know if he quite cuz obviously to defend just
like the the the scams and there's no way, right? But Tim doesn't
just do like apology. Oh, he makes mistakes but like he also
does really good things. He's like, "Trump's the best president
of my
>> in terms of how much money they are making off of his
presidency." They're not even hiding it. They are just constantly
making money off of you. As you suffer and get less and less
money, they get more and more. They are taking the pizza and
not even leaving you bits and pieces, morsels of the crust. It's
it's sad. And yet people love it. they will accept it with a
smile on their face and plea and say please give me >> it's
very easy to understand why they do that. So this is the Charlie's
I I think he probably does understand this but like a lot of
people's misunderstanding maybe Charlie's
is actually very easy to understand because you just don't understand
what their value system is. A lot of times people perceive hypocrisy
because they don't understand the scope of a person's feelings.
The fact is that they don't really care whether Trump is a scammer.
They don't care whether Trump was uh cheated on his wife or whether
he was some weirdo or some other they don't give a about that.
The only thing that they care about is that Trump is able to
enact the policies that they want him to enact.
>> Okay. So yeah, maybe he's not that maybe he's not that
smart. If I could just predict exactly his position, right?
If if I could just predict that one to one, maybe he >> Trump
is not a person to them. He is a tool. And I think that another
parallel to this is Hassan. The reason why a lot of people don't
care about the uh the the the dog at all is because Hassan represents
a value system that transcends what his individual behavior is
as a person. So Hassan and Destiny is the same thing. People
People just don't even give a [__] whether, oh, Destiny
said this thing or he did this thing. Whether he did or he didn't,
he's in this lawsuit. >> Asold's just just um describing
cultlike devotion right now. >> The reason why people still
support Destiny is because Destiny represents an idea that transcends
what an individual is responsible for. And I understand that
like you can probably look at, you know, the president of the
United States and hold them to a different standard than a YouTuber.
Sure, I think that's fair. But fundamentally, what we're talking
about is the way that humans perceive things. People will be
more than willing to accept a horrible person if that horrible
person will do something that they want.
And it's really just that simple.
And the hypocrisy for this is actually not hypocrisy. It's a
lack of perspective.
You think that their value system is what they're saying. It's
not and it never was. Their value system is actually about achieving
these meta level goals. And even if they have an imperfect messenger,
that's better than having no messenger at all.
That's the real reason >> I need to relisten to that. Hold
on. >> I have to relist to that in general. >> And
it's really just that simple. >> It's goofy guy. >> And
the hypocrisy for this is actually not hypocrisy. It's a lack
of
You think that their value system is what they're saying. It's
not and it never was. Their value system is actually about achieving
these meta level goals. And even if they have an imperfect messenger,
that's better than having no messenger at all.
That's the real reason. >> So, I understand what he's getting
at. He's just describing people as like um oh, what would you
call it? Like selfish beings, right? in general, it's like not
even something that you could really disagree with. It's just
that all of the people will deny that this is what's happening.
And so if if you're just going to argue that, well, everybody
will do this
and you're actually dumb for take it's like, okay, we shouldn't
we should just expect everybody act with greed all the time and
not ever talk to them. Not even then I guess you can't possibly
complain about anybody mischaracterizing your positions, right?
Cuz you would admit that you would do this as well. you would
have to be lying about your positions as well and then your fans
would have to lie about what they want out of the world, right?
I don't know. It's like you you could do this, but you should
to some extent engage with people's intellectualization of their
own positions and feelings and what they want from the world.
If you don't engage with it at all, if you just say, "No, no,
no. I could see that this is like he's basically advocating pe
for people who say, "Oh, you uh you're voting for Trump. Oh,
you just want America to fall. You just want America destroyed.
You actually actually you're a racist who just hates brown people,
because he would have to admit that
that's maybe the most prevalent thing people put on uh Trump
supporters is like the racism thing, right? You just want you
just want immigration enforcement in all of these cities because
you hate brown people.
I don't know. I'm also I'm like >> and once you look at
things through that >> maybe maybe he expounds in a way
that I could like engage with somehow because he's doing a lot
of the saying nothing. I'm like engaging with him like he's actually
saying something too. >> You'll understand why so many
of these issues of hypocrisy are actually not hypocrisy. People
just perceive it as hypocrisy because they've bought into the
lie that it's been about principle to begin with. It was never
about principle. This is what I've said before about how by playing
the game you often times lose. >> The more I've got more
holes for you to fill. Please come in here. How's it different
than Obama or Biden or Gavin selling a product to make seller
make a product sell? >> Nobody is guys. It's not just No,
no. He's saying it's not just BA with no principles. It's everybody
with no principles. And basically, you'll have to lie and and
cheat to try to win. And you're doing that for your goals and
that's understandable and that's the way the world works. And
to some extent, that's true. That's what you should expect in
some ways. But if that's really how everything is, then you know
what? Meteor 2026 instead of midterms, I >> I don't know.
the point you can make a >> It's sort it's like exactly
what you'd expect for him saying this like he he defines himself
as an accelerationist, right? It's like a totally nihilistic
way of looking at the world. Feels depressing to even like to
even >> Arguments about it, but like I'm talking about
a like
I don't care about that. Like that's that doesn't matter. >> What?
Oh, the music. Cherry says the music's depressing. Hold on. Apparently
the music's
low low energy. Let's get some sax music >> Or like I don't
give a [__] about that. Like that's not my point.
There's a much bigger issue and an idea that I'm talking about
here that doesn't have anything to do with any one person. And
hopefully people can understand that. >> Give me some more.
I've got more holes for you to fill. Please come in here. I'm
waiting. It It's >> Uh-huh. That's a That's a crazy time
to resume the video. >> Absurd. They don't even stick to
a single belief anymore. Like the Epstein Files, I know I have
made a lot of content on in the past, so I'm not going to regurgitate
that, but the Epstein files are a really good example of how
they really cared about the Epstein files and they were really
upset at the failure of Joe Biden to release them in that administration.
So, they were hyping up Trump about all of his promises to release
those Epstein files, which he has still not done and still actively
just like discounts in the entire admin administration denying
the existence of now. This same group of people that was so excited
for Trump to follow through on that promise is now like, "Oh,
he didn't break any promises. In fact, it's just not even important.
That's why he's not doing it." Like, it's not a big deal. Like,
who cares about the Epstein files? We have so many bigger things
to worry about like what the next product we're going to have
to buy from Trump is. >> It's going to be the phone. It's
going to be socks. Maybe. So, uh, the reason why, and this is
the reason why it happened,
a lot of the people that were proTrump were very very much in
favor of releasing the Epstein files. One second. >> Trump
said that the Epstein files weren't there. A lot of people whenever
Joe Biden was president, I think that they weren't really talking
about it a lot, too. I think that really people do care about
the Epstein files, but what they really care about is being able
to weaponize the Epstein files against their political opponents.
I'm >> That's what they really care about. And I know that
I mean he's dude like this might be true.
There has to be some concept of this. Like you basically say
everybody's bad faith. Everybody is lying about what their true
motivations are and they're only doing they're only telling you
like the things they could possibly defend other people but they're
all lying and they're all self-interested and they're all trying
their best to you over in any way possible.
It's like there has to be a limit to that kind of thinking, right?
>> There has to be. It's like so lazy.
Like then there's no reason to talk to anybody ever about anything.
You never have to speak to somebody because you just look at
their motivations and you never have to speak to them. There's
like no communicating. There's no changing people's minds on
this might be a very very tough pill to swallow. But I don't
think people really care about what happened or not. I think
a lot of people genuinely don't because Chris Brown is still
on the radio.
It is
It is equivocation.
Um I would say probably there's value in like maintaining the
veil in any case, right? Like the veil that you have where people
have to pretend outwardly and try to like do you know whatever
deception, whatever cloak and dagger behind the scenes, if you're
going to do that's like unethical, you have to do it in a way
where you don't get caught. Right? This goes back to like the
Hillary Clinton thing where it's like, okay,
so here we're arguing that everybody's corrupt, everybody's doing
this. Okay, so give me the guy who can do all those things. Give
me the woman, okay, the pants suited woman who can kill people
and get away with it. All right. Cuz I think that having the
veil there, having that like that uh that thing there where people
have to pretend that they have principles, even if even if everybody's
disingenuous, right, it at least keeps the most incompetent people
from being from being able to enrich themselves.
Like at minimum there would be an advantage to like, well, the
most competent people will be able to hide it, right? I think
I think you're forgetting the end of the sentence. It's okay
to do bad things if he wields power to get the things they want
at the end of it. That's why he can't admit it's bad before saying
it doesn't matter.
Sure. Sure. And he beat the out of Rihanna. You have people like
Shawn Penn that beat the out of Madonna. You have people like
uh Chuck Barry that married like a 14-year-old. You have tons
of people that have done all these horrible things and the public
has accepted them to a general extent. This is true and it's
undeniable. And I understand that.
Okay. Wait.
I Wait, hold on. Asminold,
if would you keep listening to Chuck Barry right now? If it if
it was right now and he was like a
he was like a drill rapper and he was a 14-year-old, would you
just go, "Well, that's fine. People do." Is that
Is that real? Is that what you do?
I don't What is this argument? Hey, really bad happens to everybody
all the time, guys. Why are you mad about it? Haven't you thought
about how really bad things happen all over the place all the
time? People do bad things and then they get away with it kind
of. >> You know, again, by me saying this, people might
think that it's problematic, but I can come up with a lot more
examples if you want. Jerry Seinfeld, people love Jerry Seinfeld.
He dated a 17-year-old girl, but do people still watch him? Yeah,
they sure do. They think he's funny. And so, a lot Yeah. And
I can go on and on. Elvis people, too. Like, yeah. On and on
and on about this, right? And so the point that I'm making about
it is that the people that really care
>> uh
yeah, I guess Asmin Gold's only only way to to defend you or
the only the only thing he cares about. He can forgive every
sin is just if you were born in the US. You're born outside of
the US. Okay. You come in, you're like a perfectly acceptable
US citizen. No, you got to go. No, we got to destroy your life.
Okay. You [__] a 14-year-old repeatedly. Um, wait,
were you born here? Okay, no, it's fine. We let it go. Not a
big deal, man. Not a big deal, >> About the Epstein files
primarily cared about it as a tool to weaponize against their
political opponents.
I think if the Epstein files were theoretically released and
Trump wasn't in them, theoretically,
then all of the people that were uh Democrats would not accept
them,
even if they were real. I'm talking about a hypothetical.
If there's a hypothetical that if they were released and Trump
was not in the files and not implicated, I think they would not
accept them. And I'll even go a step further. I think that if
Biden had released them and wait, why even entertain this hypothetical
when we know Trump is in the files? A
>> why why are you even entertaining this
You just made up a hypothetical that one of the few hypotheticals
about the Epstein files we know is not true. You just took like
the only one of the only things we know about them is that Trump's
name is plastered all over them and you just gave us a hypothetical
where that isn't the case. >> Bill Clinton wasn't in them
and a number of other key people were not in them that were left-leaning.
The Republicans would not accept them either.
And I think that you have to look again. This is what I've said
before. You might think that this is hypocritical,
>> but that's hold on. That's Why is that Asmin Gold? That's
because we have a lot of evidence that these dudes hung out in
real life, took the plane with him, were like real actual friends
of him for a long time. That's why it would be unbelievable.
It's not just all politics. It has to do with these people having
real substantial uh substantial relationships with Bill uh not
Bill Quinn, Jeffrey Epstein for a long time. That's because you're
not looking at it from the perspective of where their real values
are. The real value is weaponizing this to hurt people that you
don't like.
And I think that this is what I've said before, right? How do
I understand and try to perceive what people think?
I think of the lowest,
most base,
most selfish,
selfserving thing that people could possibly believe.
That's why. And I think that I'm right pretty much every single
time. And that's it. It's sad you have to keep saying the same
thing as people don't listen. Well, it's because people don't
like people I think it's not that people don't listen, it's that
people don't want to listen.
That's the reason why because I think that people don't want
to hear this. It it it's not it's a very unpleasant reality,
isn't it? I think it's an extremely unpleasant reality,
but it is reality.
It's my understanding of reality at >> They're just now
saying it doesn't matter. We don't care. We actually don't want
this information. Actually, I believe everything they're saying
now. Yeah, it definitely doesn't exist. Yeah, actually Maxwell
is probably innocent, too. But again, I I've already talked about
that a lot. Let's talk about some other stuff. The COVID vaccine.
Trump just got a COVID booster. Not a conspiracy. Just out in
the open, signed, documented, stamped. It is legitimate. Trump
just got a COVID booster. And this administration has constantly
played into the MAGA fear of the jab. That was one of the big
things with MAGA is like how this is, you know, contaminating
us, poisoning us. They're trying to kill us with the jab >> and
now Trump just got the vaccine booster and those same people
like Gunther Dicklman are now applauding him for it, sucking
a
>> Oh, this is like actually a lot of this is way more
disappointing for Asminold. I just would have thought, hey, uh,
Trump actually liked the vaccine the whole time cuz he did it.
He did operation warp speed >> out of his butt for it.
giving him a full rim job. Like, yes, the president's healthy.
This is great news. Meanwhile, only a few months ago, a big talking
point from him and so many others is the COVID vaccine and the
evil of it. But now that Trump got the vaccine booster, well,
now they love it. Well, now it's great. Actually, Trump probably
got the vaccine booster because he's going to immediately give
all of us herd immunity. He is using himself as a selfless sacrifice
with the jab. So that way his aura of being immune to CO will
help infiltrate all of us via >> I think that the COVID
vaccine controversy
was not really about the vaccine itself.
I think that the real controversy was about the fact that you
couldn't question it and it was
for a lot of different reasons.
That was the real reason why people got radicalized against the
COVID vaccine. I think that if you just looked at it and I I
think that's really what happened and so basically whenever you
had to get a vaccine like there is a very very strong line and
I think that people find it to be very uncomfortable whenever
there is compelled medical behavior like you have to take this
medical thing and I think that really
I if you're just like a logical reasonable person you see that
this vaccine comes out it's been out the co has happened for
a year. a lot of other vaccines. There's, you know, these have
been out for a very, very long time. And so people have a lot
more trust in, let's say, the polio vac. >> Okay, so the
ma people who didn't like the co vaccines, it was just that they
like, you know, they had some justifiable skepticism and now
that there hasn't been a mass die off, they're totally convinced
CO vaccines are fine now. Okay. Um, okay. >> Vaccine first.
>> Of course, I don't believe that at all. I think all
of these people I still see the same amount of like skepticism
basically everywhere in life with the co jabs. Right.
I I've not seen this change anywhere. I have no idea what this
is informed by at all. >> Does the COVID vaccine because
of its tenure? So this vaccine >> remember when that woman
fainted in live TV? They didn't replay that much. Hold on. Let
me uh let me move this and read his chat. I think this would
be the best thing the best the best tool right now. Be watching
his chat a little bit. My problem was being hip was Hippo was
being violated by businesses mandating proof of vaccination.
Something that big should have been independently tested, not
tested by the same people who produced it. Feel like you were
just dismantling this video. Wait, what? >> Comes out and
immediately people have to accept it as being completely valid,
totally problem. >> But the omocron variant, I hope we
can heal as a society. I really do. You seen the South Korean
study on the side effects of the COVID vaccine? Bro, so many
people in his audience are actually still skeptical of it.
Like openly still skeptical of it. Like I'm reading a bunch of
posts of people obviously still being skeptical. Oh, >> totally
unproatic. And you had government officials at the time saying
that if you got the vaccine, you >> if people had treated
the COVID vaccine like every other vaccine required for public
school, we'd be fine. Yes.
The time it was proven it did not work like intended. COVID vaccine
at the elderly, the sick who need it. Trump is old, by the way.
Uh, my problem was you couldn't question the science. It killed
my dad in four weeks. I had never heard Trump. This is the actual
one. Trump's never called the COVID vaccine bad, which is a big
deal. Never got the jab because I'm lazy and wanted to play video
games. Average >> get which turned out later on to not
be true. And I think that a lot of reasonable, rational people.
>> When they tried to compel kids to get it, when kids
on average don't get serious CO, it made my parents go nuts.
I think there was some understanding or some thought of fish
at the time early on that getting everybody to get it would cut
down on transmission. It could cut down on viral load. People
thought viral load is very likely connected to how how uh what
do you call it? Contagious it is coming from you. And so they
wanted everybody to get it to cut down on the viral load. It
seemed like the children weren't susceptible to it, but they
weren't sure if they I I think kids still build up a viral load
even though they're immune. People saw that and it made them
extremely uncomfortable and the fact that they couldn't express
that discomfort and they also couldn't behave according to that
discomfort
and they were compelled by either the government or by their
job or by society as a whole to behave in this way and to undergo
medical treatment that they were not necessarily confident about.
That's the real reason why people were upset
>> Yeah, exactly. But the thought was Porter Beller. Yeah,
that's my point is kids still transmit is they thought that because
it would kill off your viral load. It would drop the viral load
from COVID very significantly. They thought then okay, that's
going to reduce transmission. We're not going to have as many
people giving the virus as like
uh as contagiously. >> The COVID vaccine,
I think that's really what happened. And if the COVID vaccine
wasn't as, you know, pseudo mandatory culturally,
um, I don't think that you would have really had the same type
of push back if they had come out and said, well, you know, we
don't know whether this is going to completely stop it, but we're
doing our best and this is our first attempt at it right now,
and there's people discussing it online, whether it's doing,
it's a controversial topic, etc.
Guys, I'm sure just as many people actually if they wouldn't
have made it mandatory, I think more people would have um Yeah,
sorry. That's what I'm saying. Sub uh substance is I'm saying
they thought it would cut down viral load, cut people's like
transmissiveness of the virus. I think there was evidence with
at least a delta variant that you still transmitted the virus
significantly with the vaccine
that like the vaccine was not actually making you transmit the
virus less,
right? or not significantly less. Not like a lot less, like a
maybe a little bit less. I think that was the Delta variant,
I think. But like, trust me, I'm not trying to do misinformation.
This is just my best recollection of what was going on. Um,
yeah. Anyway,
uh, what was he about to say? He was about to say I think he's
saying something along the lines of, "Guys, if we didn't make
it mandatory, we actually would have had more people get the
vaccine." Just so you know, more people would have gotten it
if it wasn't
we would have done better. >> I don't think that you even
see 10% of the hostility and the paranoia that's happened. And
I I think that really the proof is in the pudding. You can look
at in retrospect the amount of trust that the government I think
has lost after co think about how much people distrust the government
because of how co dude I remember during co the argument I made
for why you shouldn't have mandatory vaccines or you shouldn't
do I think lockdowns were the bigger one for me. I thought I
felt like with lockdowns, with a lot of the distancing stuff,
a lot of the measures they put into place, at least not outside
of like the major the extreme metropolitan centers where you
have like insane population density. For me personally, I was
just like, "Oh, you should just tank the deaths." Like just some
people are going to die, but tank it and like let everybody build
up immunity that way. You get you get a lot more deaths, but
you just hope the hospitals hold and you you don't do the economic
damage. You don't do the societal fabric damage, right? you don't
have kids who don't go to school and like socialize for for a
year. You just like tank. That was my I wanted to do that. I
think that could have been fine. I think that would have ended
up being fine to be honest with you. Um I think I think that
was the better course, but I don't think that um yeah, some countries
did do that, Maximus. Yeah. Didn't Sweden did something like
that? Yes. Um I think they still had impacts. I think once only
one country does it as well the e- the global economy is so integrated
that you don't escape the effects right like 95% to 99% of countries
doing it you're just [__] already right or first
world economies
like you're not going to escape the effects of the economic devastation
because you're the one country that didn't do it but I understand
why people didn't do it too right
>> like I totally get why
why it was scary like if you overwhelm hospitals you have mass
die offs Right? If you have if you have like mass die offs and
you're like you're you might you might get [__] you
might get put on trial for like war crimes or something like
war crimes against humanity or something, right?
>> Depending on and you don't really know if there's going
to be variants that increase the the lethality or how quickly
it transmits or whatever, right? I think there's different measures,
but you don't know if that's going to happen. So, I totally understand
why people took a cautious approach. I don't think that was like
totally incorrect. It was like I was like 6040 in the tank the
mass deaths thing.
>> Bunch of people dying is arguably bad for the fabric
of society. Yeah. But it was mostly a risk to people who are
retired to be honest, not contributors.
Even though I love a lot of those people, right? Like my family
would have been old. Um it was it's a risk to people who are
who can better who can less damagingly absorb the risk was handled.
And I think also, this is a point Charlie isn't bringing up,
the COVID vaccine was developed under under Trump to to a pretty
large degree. I mean, it was now it was announced a couple of
days after the elections were over, but at the end of the day,
it was still under his presidency. It was developed under him.
So, operational. Yeah. Exactly right. And so, I don't I don't
know why he's not bringing that up. I feel like that's probably
that's probably the best example of it. But I think it's really
about people not being able to question and push back against
it. And even and and this could be a Mandela effect. I don't
know if it is, but I remember hearing when the
>> uh this is probably this could easily be true. That's
the thing. Evil Johnny Bravo. I feel like anybody who can acknowledge
that like lockdowns were almost were bordering on a coin flip
on whether or not that was a good decision. If you act like it
was obviously true that lockdowns were just horrible for society
no matter what you're you're not somebody who should be spoken
to basically you're like a total
and like on the other side if you think like it was obvious that
um that like vaccines not vaccines if it was obvious that like
unlockdowns one way or the other vaccines I think um just almost
universally good right I just I took the vaccine I didn't have
any problem taking the vaccine I think I waited a little bit
So, I waited a little bit and was like, h, I'm going to see what
happens. And then after like a couple months, maybe like a month.
I was like, I'll do it. [__] it. Enough people got
it now that I don't even know like what's going to happen if
this actually does kill all of us. I don't know if I even want
to live in that world. So, vaccines were being announced that
they were not announced intentionally before the election because
they might change the results of the election. I don't know necessarily
if I'm remembering correctly, but I remember hearing things like
that. So yet we can trust Trump. Well, what I'm saying is that
I'm not saying you can trust anybody, but what I am saying is
that telling people that they have to trust something is very
different. Wait, BB Poison, does that work though? Can you Can
you actually lock down just the old people? If all the young
people go out, get the virus, and bring it home and take care
of those old people. Aren't those old people still I guess if
you want to go to an old person's home, you need like uh PPE,
but I don't know. I think old people might still be [__]
in that case. osmosis. So now we're all immune to CO Trump getting
the COVID vaccine booster or some crazy [__] Maybe
that one I'm just spitballing, but I'm trying to find ways they'll
mental gymnastics around it. But the sad reality is they're not
even going to bother trying. they're just going to be like, >> and
I think also there were a lot of people of the mindset that like
my dad had this mindset that, you know, because he was, you know,
he had already gone through like he got the COVID vaccine
because he had Oh, also, um, I'm going to use the bathroom really
quickly, but I think we need what do we got like 5 minutes left?
Yeah, 5 minutes. We need five subs. Let's get those five subs
in 5 minutes. Uh, or we'll have whatever amount. 25. Okay, I'll
be right back. I'm not going to show a lot. Um, like I said,
I was hung over. So, we'll finish the segment no matter what.
After this, I've still got like a big Nick Fentes debate with
Gavin McKinnis
and a couple other things that I'm I might still come back and
do them. We'll see. Try to hit those five subs. >> People
of the mindset that like my dad had this mindset that, you know,
because he was, you know, he had already gone through like he
got the COVID vaccine because he had already gone through pneumonia
multiple times, he was missing part of his lung and he was se.
So I think that there was a lot more people that were willing
to get the COVID vaccine that were immuno compromised in one
way or another, right? But whenever you compare that to it being
compelled on healthy, you know, athletic uh 30-year-old adults,
well then that's a very different conversation, isn't it? And
I think that's another layer to the complexity that again makes
Trump more makes people more accepting of it. And I do think
that Charlie is to a degree right that there is a lot of dissonance
that happens and it's like when Trump does it it's okay. I think
again the crypto example is better than this example. But I do
think it's true. But I'm just explaining a little bit more behind
this
>> Charlie just totally up his entire crypto point, right?
Charlie just totally this up. It's like not even
acceptable. Whatever the [__] his point was supposed
to be here. Like Charlie's Charlie's point should have been um
Trump literally made the co vaccines and all these people vote
for him. Not Trump got a co booster and all these people vote
for him cuz realistically
the problem they have is co being co vaccines being forced on
all of them. It's not Trump making the decision to get a for
a COVID vaccine. That's like not that big a deal to them >> and
just be like the good little NPC drone that's like anything Trump
does is great. can't wait to swallow more Trump meat. Even though
it goes completely against all of >> you just about RFK
with his attacks on a vaccine, right? Well, I don't know everything
that RSK has said. I mean, I I I don't know. I think that vaccines
should be will you should be able to criticize vaccines and people
should should have every right to be reluctant to take vaccines.
They should have every right to be reluctant.
I don't have an issue with vaccines. I have an issue with you
having an issue with other people that have an issue with vaccines.
Does that make sense? People should be allowed to come to their
own conclusions and they should make their own decisions for
their own life and make their own medical decisions.
If I had a kid, I'd get my kid
I probably wouldn't get him the COVID vaccine, but I definitely
get them to polio one. What are we talking about? Of course he
was talking about like so many people that were talking about
the jab and how evil it is and all of that are now celebrating
that Trump got it. That's just it's just so obvious. It's so
blatant. Like [__] cat turd. I I don't think I've
seen anything from him on Trump getting the jab here. Just radio
silence. Just crickets. It's just ignore things that make you
have to think. That is the cult mentality of MAGA. Anything Trump
does is perfect. Anything that makes me think that maybe there's
something else there, I shut out. I plug my ears to. It is horrifying.
I think that this is true and I think that this is a massive
issue, but I don't think that Trump has a monopoly on cult behavior.
I think that you can look at especially the way that a lot of
the free Palestine people reacted to the peace agreement and
the ceasefire with Gaza.
>> Wait, is the Caimoke getting shocked? Yes, the Kaiam
gets shocked
intimately. Okay, this does happen. as the opposite. How is it
that you can protest and fight and complain and get mad about
this for two years, but you know, actions are taken? And again,
keep in mind, I'm not happy about this. Israelis are happy about
this.
Israelis are dancing about this. Palestin,
is that the Is that the phrasing you want to use there? Is that
the precise? The Israelis are dancing about this, are they? Okay.
>> Palians are dancing about this. They're the ones that
are happy. >> So, shouldn't you at least be happy that
they're happy?
>> Well, I don't hear any of that. >> So, I think
this cult behavior is nobody has a monopoly on cult behavior.
That's my point that I'm making. >> Is now building a Qatari
Air Force base in Idaho. Trump has accepted a huge $400 million
Wombo Turbo Superstar jet from Qatar. Wombo Turbo. >> And
it's a crazy gift. That's one hell of a donation. >> That's
a nice one, huh? >> In there. I don't want to toss the
B- word around too late. >> So,
another thing that I I don't know. Did Charlie make it clear?
I think that the big deal with that jet is that it's supposed
to revert to being Trump's personal property after the end of
his term, right?
Isn't that the big deal with the jet that it's like literally
a personal gift? It's like a political gift that they're giving
that turns into a personal gift eventually.
here the bribe nomenclature but I mean definitely smells a little
fishy over here with that especially >> oh is it being
donated to the presidential library after maybe I think the thing
with the um oh what is it the thing with the jet is that I think
the jet from what I've read it's like so expensive to maintain
the jet yes the jet is so expensive to maintain that they don't
want to even keep like the jet was probably something the Qataris
were like oh this burning a hole in our pockets. Actually, get
rid of this [__] jet. This jet's [__]
useless. >> In regards to what came soon after, he then
signed a 5.5 billion dollar deal with Qar for a Trump golf course.
Yippee. That's great for the American. >> That's right.
That's right. This is what's going to happen.
>> That is Trump wealth here through this deal. And now
he is putting a Qatar Air Force base on our homeland soil. America.
So, that's not really the entire thing, but I do I I can see
why Charlie would be confused by this because their messaging
like Pete Hex's messaging about this and also JD Vance's messaging
about this was contradictory and it was confusing to people and
they should have they should have done a better job with this
to be fair. But what happened really is that there was a >> Oh,
Asmin Gold's going to actually get this correct and Charlie's
going to it up. God damn it. deal that Trump finalized or not
Trump finalized but Trump approved in 2017. And this deal was
even it was like the workings of this deal were beginning in
2016 with the Obama administration. This is where we were selling
I think it was 36
godamn it F-15 QAS. God
[__] he's he's he's becoming informed. He's starting
to learn. Oh god. Oh god. He's starting to learn. uh F-15 jets
to Qar for like 12 billion something like this and and you can
see it's like each one's like 300 and something $30 million right
it's a lot of money well with a lot of really expensive things
it's very common that you're also sold a training program for
those things and this deal and and the point that I'm making
with the deal is this deal has gone through three separate presidencies
it was initially floated by the Obama presidency it was been
uh you know approved.
>> We don't know that it was floated by the Obama presidency.
We don't know. I think Trump approved the sale in 2017, right?
We don't know how much the training program was offered or what
it was like how exactly it was promised when the original deal
was being negotiated.
We don't have like a good idea of how maybeQatara was like, "Oh,
we really need training." And they're like, "Ah, we don't know
about having you on our bases." You don't know how it looked
at first, but it was something that obviously they would have
probably talked about to get them to buy the Jets, right? >> By
the Trump presidency. It was then pretty much continued by the
Biden presidency and it was finalized again by the Trump presidency.
So, this really isn't a Donald Trump like Donald Trump does not
own this issue. It's just simply something that's been going
on for a very long period of time.
This is the same thing whenever you sell those jets. A lot of
people come here and they're trained also to use the jets. This
is part of the sales package and they're able to do that. So
these people that are Qatari uh you know pilots are going to
come to America and be trained here on an American air base,
but they're going to have their own space there in order to be
trained. And so that does not mean that Qar is building an air
base in America. Like the same way that we have bases in other
countries, that's not what Qatar is doing. But they're having
people trained here in order to use the jets that they bought
for 12 million 12 billion dollars.
I'm fine with that. Yeah, I'm fine with that, too. I don't think
it's a big deal. >> You notice that Moist Critical has
one nostril much bigger than the other. No, I've never noticed.
>> Now, you could say it's a guitar base. Well, you you
can look it up for
>> You can't say it's a guitar base. It's
stupid. The US is going to build it. They're going to build it.
They're going to design it. They're going to manage it and maintain
it. Qatar is just giving them money to do so. Qatar is not going
to hire their own contractors to go build the buildings on a
US air base. The US military is never going to let another country
do that. Obviously, it's a facility, is not a base. Yeah. Yeah.
You you can look it up for yourself. Like I I again, you can
go back and forth and you you can decide this whatever you want,
but you just look this up and that's clearly what it is.
That changes everything. uh maybe y'all should construct an air
base with North Korea and the US. Well, we'll see what happens,
right? And uh anyway, so and but this has happened with a lot
of cases now. And and I think that if you want to have a problem
uh and say like, well, Qatar is a funer and a sponsor of terrorism
and because of that, we're not going to do business with them
and we don't think >> terrorism is soar is like Hassan
[__] Like Qatar is like the country version of Hassan
[__] is what you're saying. Oh, they sound very bad
to me. >> You know, I don't think we should do business
with them at all. That's totally fine for you to think that,
but I don't think that's something that you can leverage explicitly
at Trump because again, this deal had gone through approval effectively
through three different administrations,
three separate administrations. Trump said that exact same. Like
I I still I don't understand. It was floated or it was entertained
by three different administrations. It didn't go through approval
for three different administrations. Only one administration
approved it, right? It was obviously floated or entertained or
however you want to put it, but like approved by three. No, it
was like only approved by one. That's just a weird way to put
that thing. Well, yeah, but that's all I'm saying. The golf course
though. Yeah, sure. Sure. You You want to complain about that?
Uh, will you let you train here if you build a golf course? Yeah.
I mean, that's totally fine. US is an air base in Iraq. We already
do this with Saudi Arabian pilots. Yeah. Yeah. No, we do it with
a lot of other countries, too. Uh, it's a very common pattern.
Like obviously whenever we sell people $12 billion worth of jets,
we want them to understand how to fly the jets. So they come
over here and they learn how to fly the jets. One of the other
reasons why is that some of the training tools and training resources
are only available in America. Like obviously Qatar, the reason
why they're buying the jets is because they're not making them.
They don't have them. So because they don't have them, they also
don't have the training tools in order to train people to use
the jets either.
So that's the reason. It's been happening for decades. Yes, it
has. And you can look this up. Oh, you missed earlier BB Poison.
He was willing to actually say that the uh the cryptocoin that
Trump made $3 billion off of that that was transparently like
corrupt.
So, hey, he's got some line. What will he do now that Trump is
being like declared transparently corrupt? Uh
Nothing at all. But I mean, he did say it about Biden's net worth
doubling during his his administration. Well, that's what I've
said before, like, and I said this at the beginning of the video,
is that this is an existential problem for all political parties.
Money being involved in politics is pollution.
But I don't think that any group and any person Nancy Pelosi
does not have a monopoly on this. Neither do any What?
Hold on. What did you just send me? Porter Beller. Trump's current
and former US ambassadors to Israel, Mike Huckabe and David M.
Freriedman performed a rendition of Sweet Home Alabama in Israel
titled Sweet Home
The lyrics were push were changed to push for Greater Israel.
Please forgive me for posting this. Wait, where's Hakabe? I don't
see Hakabe here. Oh, that No, that is Huckabe. Never mind. Oh,
I thought that was somebody else. What the [__] dude?
Mike Huckabe look old. Mike Huckabe look run down. What the That's
Mike Hakabe, isn't it?
No, that can't be Mike Huckabe. What?
That can't be right. That is bro. He run >> Torah scrolls
keep on turn. Just two days and we are through
brah.
Then we start from the beginning. Hashem's holy words begin a
new. We all have come to help
and we want to help it thrive based right here in God's holy
city.
>> Dude, this is this is so bizarre. This is not AI. This
is real. This is actual
This is literally real. >> Throughout this land, it's saving
lives. >> Sorry. Cherry asked if this was AI. It's not
AI.
>> where God's words ring so true. Sweet
Lord, I'm coming home to you. Well, friends and friends don't
think it's true. The United Nations call us crooks,
>> but Donald Trump claims it's all Israel,
just as it says in all the holy books.
Okay, hold on, hold on, hold on. I got to listen. >> Friends,
don't think it's
>> Oh, hold on.
Wait. I didn't think that was what it was doing, but they're
obviously referring to calling Palestine a country, recognizing
Palestine is a country,
right? And what does he say to that? To France and the other
countries who don't think that Palestine is >> the United
Nations call us crooks. >> Hold on. But Donald Trump claims
it's all Israel,
>> just as it says in all the holy books.
>> bro. That that whole Palestine, that's all Israel. Okay.
Now, I actually don't think that's necessarily
greater Israel. I think you need a lot of Jordan for greater
Israel, don't you? Hold on. Greater Israel.
Let me let me let me look. Greater Israel
is Hold on. Greater Israel would be would it wouldn't be this
whole thing, would it? The royal grant. It would not be this
whole thing. No way. Oh, yeah. No, it would be this thing, right?
The approximation of the royal grant to Abraham consisting of
all land east of the brook of Egypt and west of the Euphrates.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, yeah, you need a lot more. You need
a lot of Syria. You need all of Jordan, it looks like basically.
Yeah. Yeah. And Iraq. Okay. All right. Now, there is some version
of like the uh what is it? Netanyahu's party, man. There is it's
the Lood. I didn't I can't even see it here. Lood charter that
says they have to reclaim greater Israel. That's the mission
of the party, right? Yeah, I know. I got it before I looked it
up. I was just like
the brain not not work so good tonight. Okay. Jesus.
Lude lood chair. Lood lood. I thought it was the the basically
the charter of this party is like about reclaiming greater Israel,
right? Okay. I'm not caught up on the greater Israel thing. Is
it not just a skitso idea of the extreme right in Israel? Like
it's never going to happen. Um I mean this is the ruling party
of Israel that says it's a part of their charter.
No, I I don't know. Why would they Oh, why would they sing the
song Maximus? Because the idea is far more prevalent than anybody
in Israel is willing to admit to people outside of Israel. The
idea is like not even remotely a pipe dream to them. to the current
ruling party in Israel. It is not a pipe dream at all. Like,
hold on. Is there anything in here for
So, it's a it's a merger of
So, Lood, National Liberal Movement is a is a merger of And the
party list includes the Movement for Greater Israel.
Uh, cool.
That's literally It's weird.
Okay. Okay. Movement for greater Israel.
Pursuing peace, Netanyahu and his party turned away from greater
Israel in 2019.
Huh.
The coup, despite defections, has joined labor in accepting the
inevitability of territorial compromise. Israel could take over
Syria, Jordan, and Iraq without taking losses. That's not true,
evil Morty. That's that's implying a world where nothing in the
world changes and people just back off and let Israel fight all
three of those wars at the same time. Do you think that's the
world we live in? Do you think all of the people around
would allow that to happen? You think Turkeyy's not doing anything?
If if Israel Oh, actually, Evil Morty setting us up to go into
the next part of the stream, which is probably now that we haven't
gotten donations going to be my super boring video that I want
to watch with you guys on
Turkeykey's influence in Syria. Where is this video? Where is
this video? Turkey and HTS influence in Syria. >> At the
end of the year in Yeah. Why Israel and Turkey are heading to
war over Syria. All right. You think Turkeykey's going to sit
back? You think Russia's going to sit back? I think Russia would
definitely be looking to get out anything they could to help.
Although, who knows what they can afford to spare right now?
I don't know if anybody's going to sit back on that one. Certainly,
I don't think Saudi Arabia is going to sit back while a larger
power forms on their border,
right?
I don't think so. Anyway,
I do have to finish >> the Republican senators that have
made even more money than she has. Uh, neither does Donald Trump.
None of them have a monopoly on this. This is a meta level problem.
>> Citizens United. Yeah, there's there's that, too.
Anyway, let's move on. The Qatar thing is disingenuous. It's
a training base on a military base for Qatar. I I know that,
but that's why I'm explaining it. >> America first, right?
Yeah, it's really America first thinking right there. Yeah. And
then I've already seen the cope about how actually no this is
a this is a joint training procedure. This is something that
we do all the time actually. And I saw JD my chemical romance
Vance talking today about like how it's actually just all fake
news and stuff even though they have literally verbatim point
blank said exactly what this deal is and he is >> exactly
and they shouldn't have said it that way. It was a mistake. It
was an error in communication. They shouldn't have communicated
it that way. It was stupid. I mean, why did they just come out
and say it with like did they just shoot themselves in the foot
over this and say it was an air base like a Qatari air base or
something?
>> Just denying that. So, not even the ad >> I don't
know how anybody would even believe that. How did reporters not
go my first my first reaction to hearing that was no, the US
the US military would never allow that. Like the the entirety
of the US military would go, "No, no, no. That's stupid. That's
never
I just I I don't know why nobody thought to just point that out
that that's obviously not something that's possible. >> Administration
is on in is in agreement on their talking points right now. It's
a mess. >> And that that's I think that's a fair criticism
to be to be honest. Like them not being aligned on explaining
how Qatar is going to be trained, Qatari pilots are going to
be trained here in the United States. I think that is that's
definitely a fair criticism because it's confusing to to people
and it it scares them. >> Still, people are so brainwashed
and mind controlled that they'll just accept it and be like this
is great. This is America first actually to put this Qara Air
Force base in Idaho. That's actually exactly what I wanted. If
you also want my opinion, I I think like on on a meta level opinion,
I think that more interplay in terms of economics with Middle
Eastern countries will be a good thing in the same way that I
think that it's been a good thing between America and China because
it lowers the probability of any sort of problematic behavior
because nobody wants to with their money. So like even if you
take the Qatar thing, >> wait, what? What is this relevant
clip?
Relevant clip. Relevant clip.
The smallest feline in the world. A rusty spotted cat. >> He
may look like a kitten. He'd still fit in the palm of your hand.
But this little male is very nearly fully grown. He'll soon be
setting off on a solitary life, fending entirely for himself.
>> Wait, how have they not like grabbed these out of the
Amazon and like bred them and domesticated them? Hello? Can somebody
explain this to me? Why doesn't like everybody own one of these?
What he lacks in size, he makes up for
in daring. Young cats are born curious. It's how they learn about
their world, even if it can get them into trouble. Straight away,
he puts his super senses through their paces.
His eyes are six times more powerful than our own and sensitive
to the slightest movement. >> Wow, that was incredibly
relevant. I'm glad I know this now. >> Out of this. I I
agree. >> Sherry sent this, I'm assuming. Yes. Very perceptive
of you. Very perceptive.
Incredible.
How did you know? How did you guess, Evil Morty? How did you
ever guess that Cherry sent this?
>> With the fundamental idea of it because I think that
peace through trade is a legitimate strategy
because nobody wants to lose money.
What do you know about economics? Nothing. I'm just making it
all up. Yeah. I'm >> That's just like generally accepted
common wisdom, right? that free trade and economic ties, this
is like just generally like one of the oldest set in stone political
rules,
right? You have you have a lot of trade, a lot of prosperous
trade with some country. You're not going to go to war with them
because you don't want and you don't even want them going to
war and disrupting the the supply of whatever thing there is
there. Making it up. That's right. That's what I think is going
to happen. Yeah. Yeah. That that's the reason. >> Always
finds a way to surprise me with some crazy skits posting late
at night. So, his most recent one is uh the Biden
274 agents into the crowd on January 6th. If this is so, which
it is, a lot of very good people will be owed big apologies.
What a scam. Do something. President DJT.
There is so much wrong with that. I I think he forgot to take
>> Okay, I don't know how how Asminold is going to deal
with this one because this one is also just blatant misinformation.
>> suppositories because holy Trump was president on January
6th. Biden did not control the FBI. But you know what? Let's
play ball here and dive into a fever dream, a fantasy. Let's
say Joseph Biden set down his ice cream, cracked his knuckles,
and assumed direct control of the FBI on January 6th and placed
all of these agents in here just as Trump says. But why don't
you do something about it? You are the president. Who are you
asking to do something? God, Batman? Like, who are you trying
to call? Who are you trying to summon to do? think that this
is so so part of this I agree with, part of it I don't agree
with. I I I agree with the sentiment here is that Trump complains
about things too much. And I think this is something that the
administration does in general. Instead of complaining, you should
be acting like instead of complaining about the, you know, governor
or the mayor not, you know, like approving like trying to like
actively subvert ICE or stop ICE, why don't you pull them up
on the insurrection act and arrest them?
Do that.
That's what I want to see. Charge them for sedition
because Yeah. I I like I agree with Charlie, but I think in the
opposite direction. Um I No, no, no. Yeah, they're not doing
enough. Like if it was up to me, these people would be in jail.
>> Uh wait, he's There's no way. He's talking about the
FBI agents who went and tried to like stop the riot on January
6th, right? There's no way. that as gold saying he wants those
people to be put in jail or
my
did I miss something happening there he wants like the people
who are like oh there's a riot at the capital they're like storming
the capital oh I should go over there and try to help restore
the peace oh Jesus okay okay ice why did you write ice cream
all right
uh this makes no sense this is
he wait okay if that's what he's talking about sorry I looked
over at another Um, if that's what he's talking about, does he
understand that Trump is the one violating the law of the US
in trying to assert control over those those places? >> No
governor or the mayor not, you know, like approving like trying
to like actively subvert ICE or stop ICE. Why don't you pull
them up on the insurrection act and arrest them?
Do that. That's what I want to see. I would assume >> charge
them for sedition
>> because I like I agree with Charlie, but I think in
the opposite direction. Um, no, no, no. Yeah, they're not doing
enough. Like if it was up to me, these people would be in jail.
And so it's about optics. Yeah, exactly. And yeah, Trump won't
then the CI because the civil war Oh, they're not going to have
a civil war. It's going to be over in sec. It'd be over in minutes.
Don't even tell them it's going to happen. Do it in in one day.
And so, uh, Trump pardoned them. Well, Trump pardoned the some
of the January 6 people and that that's complex.
But anyway, um I think that there's so I do agree with that part.
I think that it's very obvious also that whenever you have the
government that's like this massive machine, I think this massive
machine probably endures and has its own internal politics that
sometimes does not align with what the politics of the current
administration is. And I think that like probably the most obvious
example of this is the Supreme Court. The Supreme Court is basically
like Biden didn't really get the chance to appoint a lot of justices
whereas Trump in his first term did. Trump stacked the court
and because of the fact that Trump stacked the court, that is
one apparatus of the government that is effectively politicized
in a way that's beneficial to him. And I think that the same
thing is probably also true inside of the CIA. I think that it's
true inside of the FBI. I think it's it's true inside of every
apparatus of government is that there is going to be its own
internal politics. And for me to imagine that the FBI or something
like that was not was like completely in lock step with the president
all the time. I mean, just to very cursory look at the JFK files
would prove that to not be true. So, I think that in general
the deep state is a legitimate problem, but I don't think that
Trump has done even remotely enough to
undo the deep state
You think there were a large number of federal agents January
6th and incited the crowd with the >> uh it was definitely
Obama who got
Um Obama was the one who was supposed to have a justice. Biden
got to I think he nominated Katanji Katanji Brown Jackson. Jackson
Brown Jackson I think. Was it making Trump look bad while Trump
was the president? Come on, ma'am. Well, I don't know whether
there were or not.
When did I ever say that? I didn't say that. I don't know all
the details. I don't know all the evidence. Why would I make
a distinction on that whenever I don't know? That's a very specific
thing. So, so yeah, of course. >> Something you are the
president. So, if this is real, why aren't you doing anything?
This is a classic president DJT maneuver here. The entire administration
really where they're like crimes from the Democrats. And I I
would easily like I mean could I imagine that they had people
come in there? Do I think that the FBI has placed agents in areas
in order to fment unrest and cause problems? Yes, I think that
they have done that. And the reason why I think they've done
that is because I think it serves their goals because it creates
a need for themselves. It's the same reason on a fundamental
level why websites keep redesigning themselves every 6 months
to a year. It's because the design team doesn't want to get
So, I think that a lot of people try to create a need for themselves
inside of their job. And I don't think the FBI is beyond that.
Why the stupid chatters keep putting words in your mouth? It's
so annoying. The reason why is because they're programmed by
media and they're programmed by other types of controlled
uh propaganda
to behave like robots. Do you think it feels weird to Asenold
that he is like one of the biggest pieces of controlled propaganda?
Do you think it feels weird to him that like he's saying this,
but he probably has an effect? Like realistically,
if you could buy one person, if you could control them like a
robot, right? If you control their entire business like a robot,
like like total control over them, right? Would you rather pay
for Barry Weiss's free press or Asminold's channel and all of
his related properties? I feel like it's not close in terms of
an influence over US politics. I think I legitimately think Asminold
has like infinitely more reach. What's the price for Asminold?
He is like one of the biggest propaganda outlets. I know who
one is. Well, the other one got I don't know $200 million or
something for their paper that gets like think their YouTube
videos get like 100,000 views a month or something. It's like
a Pavlov conditioning where it's like as soon as one person says
one thing, then that means that they're saying five other things.
>> Absolutely abhorentt
crimes that the Democrats have done. No more playing nice. No
more Mr. Nice Guy. We're showing our teeth. We're bearing our
fangs and we're going to get something done about it. And then
nothing. Exactly. It's all just posturing. It's >> This
is J. This symmetry is infuriating. The GOP blocks a judicial
nomination and stacks the Scotus. But but FBI gen 6
Trump tries to coup an election with loyalists in Congress but
Hunter B sure
is do you think like do you feel like as gold I feel like he
does something different right he's like he's doing something
where he's trying to do the like push back against his audience
but in a weak way there's like a different thing happening here
that I swear to God if I was like more awake I could describe
it better. Also this guy's in both chats. I see this guy from
both chats. What the
progu?
This guy's in my chat all the time.
He's in here a whole bunch tonight.
It's so It's so weird when I see one of my chatters in like Asmin
Gold's chat. I'm just like, how do you watch both? I actually
don't even understand. >> I totally agree with this. I
totally agree. I think that he should go absolutely Old Testament
scorched earth on them. And the fact that these people aren't
in jail, the fact that they're not being charged for treason,
sedition, other types of insane crimes, it makes me so mad.
>> I hate >> performative. It is a game and they
are playing you. They are praying upon your gullibility and your
prop your your inclination to be afraid to constantly keep you
in fear. Cuz when you are afraid and when you are convinced that
the other side is doing
>> that guy definitely followed Asmin go way before >> all
these things to get you so easy to control. You're so malleable.
That's why >> I think this is something that's not again
you know how many times have we heard that Trump is a fascist
threat to democracy. He stole the election Russia interference.
I think this is the modus operendi to almost all mainstream media
and also almost all media in general. That's why people use clickbait.
That's why people talk about extreme.
>> Okay, I don't know if I can do
I want to finish this video,
but I'm also I swear to God I'll I'll drink a lot of water tonight.
I'll show up better tomorrow. >> I I've just had like a
juice this entire
It's enticing to people. People want to be
the best thing that can happen.
>> I'm going to chill for like 2 minutes. If I feel better,
I'll keep going. If I don't feel better, I'm probably going to
call it for the night. >> A media company is a tragedy
>> because a tragedy allows everybody to talk about the
issue. And now people are tuning into the news because everybody
wants to know what's going to happen next. So I think that really
the people that truly benefit off of any sort of tragedy or any
sort of civil unrest or anything like that are the main are the
media in general. I benefit from that. Like when something really
bad happens, my channel viewership goes up and I make more money.
That's the case with Assan with Charlie. If something bad happens,
like a big crypto scam happens and Charlie covers it or you know
a video game fails in a spectacular way like Concord uh fails,
Charlie covers it, he makes money. So there is a parasitic relationship
that media has on events like this. And I think that mainstream
media that parasitic relationship has been escalated to the point
to where they actually try to propagate. And
>> yo, Puffshake, thank you very much for the gifted sub
to wired rope. Awesome.
>> So, hold on.
>> Is Asminold just discovering this concept of the media
sensationalizing disasters and making them seem more grandiose
than they really are? Or is he saying that's what's happening
with Charlie? I'm not sure which way. continue these negative
events and these problematic things and this fearful thinking
because it's beneficial for them. I think Fox does this. I think
MSNBC does it. I think CNN does it. I think that they're all
guilty.
And even smaller places like the Young Turks or like Infowars
do it. It's true.
You guys ever thought about how it's like there's this crazy
thing going on where the media might be sensationalist? They
might just want to like keep your eyes on the screen for longer.
Have you guys ever seen this? Have you ever heard about this
this like new idea that I thought about? Wow,
guys. I don't know if you've ever realized this, but the media
might be incentivized to like make things seem worse than they
are so we keep watching. Has anybody talked about >> Trump
started it, bro. Come on.
You think Trump started the idea of media hysteria? I don't think
that's >> They're playing that in the airport. >> Here's
a great example of what
>> Wow.
What? Wow. what I'm talking about.
>> Do you remember the Ocean Gate thing whenever those
guys went down to see the Titanic after it was obviously >> I'll
be I'll be like super real. That was one thing I got totally
obsessed with for some reason even though we all knew what would
happen to them. It's like I was still obsessed with it for whatever
reason for like 48 hours. I was like looking at that that subreddit
every like 5 minutes. Holy [__]
The Ocean Gate thing was awesome. Ch love the C. Dude, it was
so compelling for some reason. I don't know why. It just had
like the right mix of things going on. It was so compelling knowing
that I think it was like there's a little bit of a socialist
in everybody. When you find out like a bunch of billionaires
have like used their money to construct something that is a monument
to their hubris and then they blow up in it. It's like, "Oh,
that's cool." You realize that one guy's kid is in there and
it's like, "Ah, that's [__] up, though." So, >> revealed
that everybody died and the death was so instantaneous they didn't
even know what happened.
It was revealed later on that all remember like the countdown
for like when they're going to run out of oxygen and everything
like that. A lot of these news stations were running this countdown
and doing all of this knowing full well that 99% chance it had
already imploded and the people had been dead for hours if not
days at that point. So, how was I was kind of [__]
up of the US military to know within like minutes that those
people were all dead
and then to just hide that information for like two weeks.
Did you guys ever see that? That the US military literally detected
from that exact area because they've got underwater like sonar
mics. They've got mics all over the ocean. So they detected the
explosion like instantly
knew immediately what it was and they were just like
well we don't want to give away the fact that we knew this instantly.
We don't want to give that away. I think they they basically
just knew immediately. There was like no reason for anybody to
go out and like do a rescue operation.
There's nothing that could be done.
Yeah. The US the US military knew instantly
because they've got microphones like audio bikes all over the
ocean. Yeah. Yeah. Have you ever thought that you were going
to move through the Atlantic Ocean with a submarine or something?
No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No. Shot. >> Is it that
that happens?
Was that Trump? No. It had nothing to do with Trump. It had nothing
to do with Wait. They heard I didn't hear this. That they heard
the explosion on the boat that launched
that launched it. I didn't hear that. I'd never heard that. I
never heard that at all. Find me an example of that.
That's a great I think that's a great example of what I'm talking
about in the most in the least politically motivated situation
I can think of.
Trump does not own the idea of escalating emotional media. This
has been a problem before Trump. It's been a problem after Trump.
It will be a problem after Trump. >> All right, that's
it. They're milking it for content. Yes. Why would Israel do
this? Exactly.
>> Now about how like the Democrats are are Satan and all
of that. Yes. >> If you have all of this overwhelming evidence
that you claim to have about all these crimes and all of this
that the Democrats have done, why have you done nothing? >> Exactly.
Yes.
>> Would be just as guilty in that case. What is the the
quote? The only thing it takes for
>> Um Yeah. Yeah.
>> Wait.
Why won't this guy make eye contact? Hey, bro. Why Why aren't
you making it? I've never seen this before. This This only came
out 4 months ago.
Oh, wait. Why did they Why did they put a whole rescue crew together?
The Dude, this guy's not making eye contact at all. That guy
is averting his eyes. >> Um, yeah.
>> what was that bag? >> Drop two weights. Dropped
two weights. >> What was that, dude? Am I crazy or does
this guy like Clearly she doesn't realize it, right? I think
clearly she doesn't realize it. She probably It doesn't even
look like she realizes anything is wrong there to be honest with
you. This guy definitely realizes something is wrong 100%. This
guy instantly is like, "Oh, [__] me." Right. He like
looks up, dude. He like looks up at this guy and doesn't make
any eye contact with her.
She like looks away. Look at him. Watch the guy walk out. He
is not He is not looking at her. He is looking over here. He's
like watching the guy go out. Bro, what? >> What? You're
a >> okay. I feel like there's plausible deniability there
that
she doesn't >> want to see is something the public was
never meant to witness until now. On June 18th, 2023,
the ocean gate with all of the enhancements that I added and
then we'll reanalyze the implosion part.
>> Hold on. Maybe there's more from >> and I've beefed
up the audio just a little bit because it was very quiet. I also
added some closed captioning text for you here to easily identify
what it is that they were talking about. It's a little over 2
minutes, so I will play it in its entirety with all of the enhancements
that I added, and then we'll reanalyze the implosion part.
>> 8 seconds till the explosion. >> Um, yeah.
So now Wendy's about to see the text message from the Titan submersible
saying that they dropped two weights. >> Dropped two weights.
Titan dropped two >> Copy. Titan dropped two weights. >> So
he meant to go down fairly uh fairly light.
I think that >> she said I don't think that's exactly what
happened. Right. Holy [__] I didn't realize that
there was more Titan submersible stuff. I didn't see this when
it came
>> Go ahead. Platform. We're going to divert.
Please dive
a line that says
check for the drive >> What is say again?
>> Repeat last. >> Diver 419 free dive equipment.
A line says
it's fair
to more than five available.
The platform was light.
Therefore, we need more breaks here.
Yeah. Well, the platform uh
>> this is Stockton Rush. This is the CEO's wife. This
is like literally the the CEO, the guy who like started the whole
thing. It's his wife. He was on the sub. >> Wait can be
on the platform and just be ready to transfer to the sub.
>> Roger. Thank you for confirming.
>> Can you confirm how many bricks are on the platform
currently?
Like at this point, right, we've lost tracking. It's got to be
You got to be thinking, man. >> Okay, so that was the full
length of that video. Now, did you notice that Gary Foss just
stated here a few seconds ago, we've lost tracking.
So, this is the very first time that we've been able to see like
a fly on the wall there. Everything that the crew was going through
up on the Polar Print. >> I wonder if they talk about this.
How did they hear the boom? Was that through like some hydrophone
of their own? Was that through audio from the submarine or was
that literally how it would have sounded there in the ocean like
separated by that much? That can't be it, right? That can't be
something that reverberates through the water that badly. There's
no way, right?
That has to be through some kind of microphone. >> Prince,
when they realized that there's there's no tracking available,
we can't find Titan. We don't know where it is. So, my question
here is why was this video kept from us, the public, from the
Coast Guard for the last 2 years or so? Why wasn't it shown at
the Coast Guard Marine Board investigation the live streams that
they did last September where they showed everything else in
the world? Also, what does all of this reveal about the September
where they
>> I thought I thought they wouldn't show this. Like what?
Oh, they must have analyzed these before they put them out. Every
time I'm like looking around, I'm like, I wonder if I'll just
see like a jawbone somewhere.
>> It showed everything else in the world. Also, what does
all of this reveal about the immediate moments after contact
was lost with the Titan submersible and the human cost of deep
sea? >> So, I know I know that the um I know the fleshy
parts were vaporized. I assume like finger bones and stuff could
have been left intact, things that were small enough that they
would have been hard to compress together. I know they got mostly
turned into mist,
but I thought uh I thought that like the bones could have not
been grounded like the bones would have been ground to powder.
I don't believe >> the ambition. >> Should we find
some uh should we find some of the simulations real quick? This
is like making me happy. This is making me not feel like I'm
sick anymore. >> It's a window into a tragedy that is still
unfolding. Titanic is still taking lives over 100 years later.
Let's watch the little scene again with the implosion sound and
I'll beef it up so you can hear the thud. >> So, this video
is telling us two different things here that we didn't know before
this. So, it's giving us a great behind the scenes view of exactly
what was going on on the Polar Prince. That's the mother ship
up top there during the implosion of the Ocean Gate Titan submersible
several hundred meters below them. Um, we also get to be a fly
on the wall there and hear exactly the sound that they heard.
What we still don't understand here is did they hear the sound
just bubble up through the ocean water and then they heard it
when it got to the surface or did it make like a ping type of
a a sound like an echo off of the bottom of the polar prince
or was there a hydrophone microphone or something that they heard
on a speaker? >> oh, this guy's wondering the same thing
I'm wondering. Oh, cool. >> It's not really telling us
how it was they heard it like mechanically what was the the way
that the path of the sound got to them. But one thing's for sure,
they heard that >> that I feel like personally that can't
possibly be something going through the um the water, right?
There's no way that like pings on the hull of the boat.
I I think it can't be that that
can it? I think it can. Sound goes forever. That was loud though,
>> the sound.
And she looked and she says, "What was that bang?" So to them
it sounded like a bang.
>> Yeah, I mean and so you know Wendy Rush at this very
moment in time she has no idea that she just heard her husband
The uh Yeah, tourniquet the sound got picked up by hydrophones
like miles away. Yeah, it definitely did. But I think a hydrophone
under the water is definite. It feels like it'd be very different
from the hull of a boat picking up some reverberated sound through
water.
Or are there just like a bunch of fish somewhere that are dead?
Oh, I guess cuz they were so low, there probably wouldn't have
been a lot of fish around. Man, could you imagine if you're in
that thing and like a
like an actual giant octopus or something like comes over and
sees you, the colossal squid or something like sees you
and just like like I don't a colossal squid can't put the force
on you to break it, but just like that would feel like so to
have one of those things comes come over
along with four other men at this very instant when she heard
that bang.
Now, this video also gets this very instant when she heard that
bang. >> What? What? Why is there a hamburger there? What's
What's the hamburger doing there? Why' they Why' they send down
that capsule full of hamburger like that? That's weird. >> Now,
this video also gives us a second clue that we didn't know before.
Here, too. Is that she had a false sense of security, thinking
everything was still okay because, oh, they just got a text message
from the Titan submersible that says, "We dropped two weights."
Now, if you're not that familiar with what this means, so dropping
two weights >> is what Stockton Marsh will do when they're
inside the Ocean Gate Titan submersible and it's dropping down
and down and getting close to the Titanic. They want to begin
to kind of slow that rate of ascent there. So, they need to jettison
a little bit of weight so that it won't be coming down quite
so fast. So, in this case here, he had just texted back up to
them, we dropped two weights. And so, this usually happens a
few hundred yards away from the Titanic. So, they were getting
pretty close to the bottom. Okay, now I know what you're thinking.
You're thinking, "Hey, sound is sound. How could Wendy Rush have
possibly heard the implosion and then a few seconds later got
that text message from Titan saying, "We dropped two weights.
Hey, everything's fine. No wonder she didn't think that anything
was wrong." But why would there be a problem here? So, you're
probably thinking that wasn't the implosion she heard because
they were fine. You saw the text come in. >> Drop two weights.
Titan, drop two >> I mean, yeah. Titan dropped too. Yeah,
>> not so fast people because take a look at this. The
speed of sound in seawater is about 1500 meters per second. And
at the depth that the Titan was, we can pretty much assume that
it took about 2.53 seconds or so for the audio to reach the ship
from where the implosion was. The way they text message back
and forth to the ship is with an acoustic modem. And let me tell
you something, man. This thing is like molasses slow. If any
of you remember the old modems from the 1990s with a dial up
that made that squealing noise
and it took forever to connect and all that, that's what we're
doing here. And these acoustic modems are even slower than those.
So yes, without a doubt, the Ocean Gate Titan imploded first
before the message that they just sent that says we're dropping
two weights was able to reach all the way up to the top of the
ship surface there and be decoded by the computer. So she sees
it on the computer and goes, "You almost see a sigh of relief
on Wendy, but man, I feel so bad." So her husband and the crew
members and that the sound of that implosion shot up to the surface
faster than the text messages that said, "Hey, we just dropped
two weights." So that's what led to the lack of understanding
there that there was already an implosion. Now, what we need
to see videos on is why was there such a delay of several hours
before they called to the Coast Guard? So, hopefully that will
come out later in the investigation also. Now, there's some other
pictures that the Coast Guard released yesterday along with this
video. And so, let me show you what these are. Okay, so here's
the first new photograph that was released yesterday. And this
is on the deck of the ship that they brought up all of the Ocean
Gate Titan submersible debris on. In fact, this right here is
one of the domes that you can see. It's already been strapped
down onto the
>> I don't know. This stuff's I understand I'm not really
ner This stuff's just >> They probably brought up a couple
of baskets full of of this uh debris here. And so, I wanted to
see if I could zoom in. They didn't give us the highest resolution
in the world. This is a printed circuit board. So, I don't know
if that came from a phone or the computer. And here's another
one. But certainly, if there was any photographs or videos stored
on the phones, you're likely to still be able to recover the
chip on there by taking it off. And I've done this before many
times as an engineer in Motorola. You reflow the board and get
>> Oh, right. I would have just liked to see like, dude,
if there was like video from inside cuz they're definitely recording
video inside and people are like, "No, no, no. It's all destroyed."
I don't know if it would have been all
That would have been cool if they could have grabbed some like
video just I know it's like morbid but
like how long did they have a time where like that acoustic system
was like detecting stuff.
I don't know man. >> Get the chip off there and you reflow
it onto another good printed circuit board that has everything
fully operational and then you should be able to retrieve the
data or photographs or video. Yeah. So this looks like another
one over here. This looks like another board here. So we don't
know if this is all related to the computer system or what a
part of a plug. So I don't know what this is. So, you know, I'd
be looking for cameras and cell phones in here and maybe even
the Rubik's Cube that that the 19-year-old kid had with him.
Yeah, he wanted to break the world record and solve the Rubik's
Cube at the Titanic depth. Uh, so looks like we have possibly
more printed circuits over here. But you can see, yeah, some
stuff got kind of shredded around, but it it wasn't like pulverized
and vaporized like everybody thought that it would be. And then
over here, you can see more chunks of printed circuit board.
And the Coast Guard also released this photograph yesterday.
This right here was the original hull from 2019 that got cracked
in the And I believe this was sitting in storage at Ocean Gate
on their property. And this is kind of eerie here. They collected
up at least two of the expedition patches. So even these survived.
So I'm I'm wondering, okay, where's the clothing? Like how how
were the condition of the bodies? You know, if this survived,
then certainly maybe the clothing might have. I know the bodies
might have been like all obliterated, but certainly the clothing
you would think would have survived. Yeah, the Coast Guard also
released this picture of some of the carbon fiber pieces. Now,
there's no scale on here, so they they're not identifying how
big this is. So, I can't really tell how big any of these pieces
are. But again, this goes against the whole grain of what many
people thought was going to be that the entire thing just vaporized
and there wouldn't be anything left to find of it. But, so this
seemed to be more like just a large underwater buckling than
it was a vaporizing implosion. And they also gave us this picture
and this shows us the map of the areas that they were searching.
So, this is their search patterns here and many over overlapped
areas in this area here. And probably >> Okay, cool, cool,
cool. There was uh one more thing I was going to watch which
video evil Johnny Bravo linked. Let's see here.
Human bodies versus implosion animation.
Okay, hold on.
Going down the the depths here. Go down. Go down. 3800 m.
Oh boy. One, two,
three, four. Possible.
Explosion duration 20 milliseconds.
Brain pain response 50 milliseconds
real time.
Boom. Slow-mo.
Boom. Oh, what is that? Oh, how did I say 50? 150. Sure. I read
it correctly, but I don't know why I said it wrong. Air Force
One probably tomorrow night for Gavin versus Fuentes. Jesus,
dude.
What is What is the human version?
Jesus Christ. It's not pink mist, though. Look, there's a bunch
of pieces in this simulation. And there's a bunch of pieces that
make it out as like actual pieces.
Like there's actual pieces getting out, bro. There's no way there's
not some actual pieces down there. I'm sorry. There's some actual
pieces of like there's actual stuff.
For sure there is. How does the How does the patch on the on
the arm survive?
But no fragments of like bone and there's just no way. Dude,
there were way funnier animations than that, though.
I don't I remember a couple of them. They were way funnier than
that for a while. Okay, I'm uh I gotta go. I love you guys. I
will be back tomorrow night for another stream.
I'll be back at 100% instead of like half wanting to puke the
whole time. Imagine your last breath is just someone's bloody
vaporized atomist. Yeah, but you wouldn't even know it. You couldn't
process it in time, so it's not such a big deal. Okay, maybe
from the afterlife you're like upset, but you can't even be that
mad, man.
Can't even be that mad. Okay,
be back tomorrow. Okay, love you guys.
Have a good night. I'll be back tomorrow. I do want to cover
there's a couple things I want to go over, but uh it'll be good
to go over them tomorrow night. All right, love you guys. Talk
to you later. Bye. Bye. Good night. Good night. Good night. Good
night. Good night. Good night. Good night.